Das war's für heute, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Batman, Hulk und Spinne, ihr habt ausgedient.
Eure Zeit ist abgelaufen, eine neue Ära beginnt.
Uwe, man nimmt die grüne Laterne mit.
Sag dem Punisher Bescheid, damit der endlich Leine zieht.
Im Kampf gegen Riena habt ihr jämmerlich versagt.
Britney Spears, Celine Dion sind euch überlegen.
Die Black Eyed Peas laufen überall den ganzen Tag.
Nur ein einsamer Superheld kämpft immer noch sein Leben.
Kettenletten, wenn du ihn rufst, dann kommt er schon.
Kettenletten mit 66.000 Fr.
Kettenletten, aber vorn heißt jetzt WB.
Kettenletten, die Einbahnmetall.
Har wir Quality Options?
Haben wir Quality Options?
Poker's Quality Options.
Die Ärzte sind jetzt auf Spotify, wo wir gerade beim Thema sind.
Fall auf Amazon Music und auf auf dieser oder so habe ich noch nie verwendet.
Irgendwie spackt mein Forscher.
Jetzt geht die Vorschau sehr schön und quality options am start ist ja geil gleich beim ersten
Anlauf. Sonst muss ich immer 3-4 mal neu starten bis es bei Twitch funktioniert.
So wir machen noch da weiter wo wir gestern aufgehört haben. Wenn ich weiß um was es
geht ausrufzeichen hr tool hat nichts mit dem hessischen Rundfunk zu tun
sondern in dem Fall steht hr für Hardware-Rat.
So jetzt muss ich ein bisschen leiser.
Wie macht man das jetzt eigentlich Open Volume Mixer. Ich finde es so wir mittlerweile wo
Einstellungen versteckt sind unter Windows R.
Ok aus irgendwelchen Gründen muss ich jetzt hier rüber switchen dass ich kann darf ich
jetzt hier leiser machen. Ok ist auch witzig Edge darf man nicht die Lautstärke steuern
kann. Verwendet wahrscheinlich Microsoft irgendwelche geheimen sonst was Apis die sonst keiner verwenden
kann. Ok Leute also wir machen an der Stelle weiter wo wir gestern aufgehört haben. Ich
würde jetzt noch ein bisschen die Ärzte laufen lassen. Allein schon weil die Ärzte jetzt
auf Spotify oder Amazon Music sind was irgendwie gefühlt nur 20 Jahre gedauert hat. Ich habe
da aber wahrscheinlich auch ein paar nicht so ganz jugendfreie Sachen dabei von ganz
früher wer weiß gleich der Bann auf Twitch raus. Ok wo sind wir gestern stehen geblieben
ich wollte noch vorher irgendwas sagen was wollte ich denn sagen noch irgendwas wollte
ich achso wir müssen heute Windows installieren das wird ganz schlimm Windows in der vm weil
wir müssen ja testen ob die Aktivierung funktioniert. Eigentlich können wir die Windows install können
wir doch eigentlich schon mal anwerfen bevor wir irgendwas anderes machen. Da kann das
im Hintergrund schon mal installieren. Ich habe mir auch irgendwo hier ein ISO hingeschmissen
wenn ich jetzt wüsste wo wäre auch schon mal ganz gut. Wo habe ich mir denn das Windows
ISO hingeschmissen da das ist mir das ISO. Windows 10 809 October German von Chip null
heute naja warum auch immer man ISOs von Chip runterlädt. So ich poste den ganzen Kram
jetzt noch mal auf Twitter kurz. Was schreiben wir hier? Falls übrigens einer guten Streamtitel
die Idee hat haut raus. Ich bin einfach sowas immer ultra unkreativ. So wir machen heute
mit wir machen heute das Tool für im Stream fertig. Mittlerweile fühlt sich das tippen
auf der Corsair Tastatur echt gut an. Ich habe ja eine ganze Weile gebraucht mich dran
zu gewöhnen aber jetzt ist es wirklich ganz nice für eine Gaming Tastatur. Ich finde
die mechanische Tastatur die ich auf der Arbeit geholt habe extra die ich also quasi
nur zum tippen geholt habe finde ich auch ein ticken angenehmer. Ich habe das schon
ein Gefühl 50 mal gezeigt hier. Die ist auch deutlich billiger. Die ist rein vom Tippgefühl
her ist die viel besser als die Corsair Tastatur aber mittlerweile geht es auch so. Dafür
hat man mehr Zusatzfunktion auf dem Corsair Ding. Und zum Spielen ist sie besser. Weil
die Tasten irgendwie schneller sind. Weiß auch nicht kann man irgendwie schlecht beschreiben.
Wir machen heute das Tool für Hardverrat im Stream fertig. So. Corsair. Ja wie spricht
man sich denn sonst aus? Corsair. Wie spricht man? Wir müssen jetzt gucken wie man das ausspricht.
Corsair Aussprache. Also. Guck mal mal. Oh das ist das ist French. Na da wundert mich
ja nichts mehr. Corsair. Ne ich glaube nicht dass man das ausspricht. Corsair. Corsair.
Corsair. Ne das ähm. Oh ne da wäre ich für gebannt. Heutzutage darfst du dich nicht
mal über dicke lustig machen selbst wenn du selbst dick bist. Das ist nicht mal korrekt.
Auf Liebeslied habe ich jetzt auch kein Bock. Corsair. Ok Corsair. Ja ja ich habe mich damit
abgefunden. Hallo Rolf. Ne nicht Rolf. Roffel. Corsair. Corsair ist eher das hier. So also
wir müssen jetzt mal Windows installieren das wir die Aktivierung testen können. Ähm
deswegen. Das lassen wir das mal im Hintergrund laufen während das Ding installiert. Äh.
Moment. Wie legt man doch ein neuer Vm an? So. Hab ich eben immer gemacht. Custom. Workstation
10. Und man muss auf eine Sache achten bei wenn man Windows 10 installiert. Und zwar
muss man ihm sagen wenn er die Festplatte anlegen will ob das so geht Moefi Boot. Mal gucken.
Äh Prozessoren. Aber 2 Cores sonst zu lahm. Äh RAM haben wir genug. Use Bridge Networking.
Man muss ihm sagen an der Stelle wo er sagt ähm Create New Disk. Man muss ihm sagen dass
er alles in einem Single File storen soll. Wenn er das nicht macht klappt das nicht.
Wolltest du nicht gestern Low Latency aktivieren? Doch. Wo geht denn das? Low Latency Video.
Aber so lang ist doch die Low Latency wirklich nicht oder? Lass mal Uhrenvergleich. Kann
man den Scheiß hier irgendwie aufmachen noch? Ja. 10, 11, 12, 13, 14. Ich guck jetzt mal
wie weit ich bin hier. Naja komm wir sind 8 Sekunden. 8 Sekunden Unterschied. Das ist
nur wirklich nicht viel. Die haben schon teilweise übelst bescheuerte Texte. Alter ich wär gern
Madonnas Dickdarm. Und warum wäre er immer gerne Madonnas Dickdarm? Weil dann wäre er
immer satt. Ist doch ganz klar. So wie geht denn das hier? Ähm wo steht dann wie das
geht? To enable or simply go to your dashboard and select settings. Ok ich mach das jetzt
mal. Ich hoffe das geht. Ich hoffe das geht im laufenden Betrieb. Ok Leute ich mach das
jetzt an. Und das nächste Mal haben wir dann Low Latency Options. Wo ist das? Kommst du
überhaupt am ringen rein? Das ist mir mittlerweile. Also erstens sind da mittlerweile nicht mehr
so viele Bands die mir gefallen. Und zwar ist das unglaublich teuer geworden. Das war
das letzte Mal schon teuer wo ich da war. Und ich weiß gar nicht was mittlerweile eintritt
kostet. Ok wo ist das denn jetzt? From the select channel under settings. Ok ich hab's
natürlich auf deutsches Kanal. There you will see an option to set your optimization preference.
Low Latency. Ahja hier. Ja geringe Latenz. Am besten für Interaktion mit Zuschauer genau
zur Echtzeit. Ok ich hab das jetzt aktiviert Leute. Muss man nicht mehr speichern ne? So
jetzt ist Low Latency am Start. Nächstes Mal wollen wir mal streben anfangen. So machen
wir mal Windows install. Oh fuck hab ich auch noch Festplattenplatz. 110GB das müsste
reichen. Wie viel Platz brauchen so ne Windows Installation? Für ne nackte Installation
mit der man nichts machen reichen doch 50GB bestimmt auch raus oder? Ich find das übrigens
sehr nice muss ich jetzt mal los werden so an euch. Wie viele Leute und ich seh ja auch
im Chat sind oftmals einfach auch die gleichen. Wie viele Leute hier immer am Start sind.
Gerade bei den nicht Gaming Streams. Find ich sehr nice. Ok meinst du 40GB reichen nicht
probieren wir mal aus. Blablabla Bridged Automatic. Gucken wir mal Bridged überhaupt funktioniert
hier von dem Account aus. Was macht der da ich installiere mir Windows in der VM. Dass
ich mein Aktivierungstool testen kann. Also nein wir aktivieren mit keinen illegalen Keys
dazu sagen. Will gucken ob die Aktivierung fehlschlägt und der Key dann nicht gelöscht
wird. Das können wir nämlich testen. Wirklich die Aktivierung testen kann natürlich dann
das Airplus selber. So. Gucken wir mal installen ISO wo hab ich das komische ISO da. ISO. Ok
auf gehts. Wir schmeißen jetzt schon mal die Windows Installation an. Da können wir nachher
gleich weiter basteln. Eine Windows Installation. Ich fass es nicht. Ich glaub so ist das ganz
gut für die Windows Installation. Das lassen wir jetzt. Ja ja wir sind fertig installieren.
Ok IP ist schon mal 210. Oh wir haben den Key nicht gepresst. Ganz ganz schlimm bei
Microsoft. Wenn man den Key nicht gepresst ist Instant Loss. Auf mach Hinnern. Windows
10 please. Oh Key. Ja Key gepresst. Das ist ja mehr Intens als Battlefield. Eine Windows
in der Windows VM ist schon geil ne. Installationssprache. Kannste hier auf Englisch stellen. Na mal
ich bin ja da. Das war halt alles auf Deutsch. Weiter. Jetzt installieren. Windows Installation
halt. Wo ist die Mac VM? Hab ich nicht hier. Geht aber mittlerweile. Zwar nur mit nem inoffiziellen
VMWare Patch. Ah Microsoft war sich zu schade den Mauszeiger anzupassen im Textfeld im Installer.
Das ist natürlich auch viel zu komplex. Ich habe keinen. Produkt Key. Und wir wollen
installieren. Was installieren wir? Wir installieren Windows Pro. Was ist eigentlich der Unterschied?
Ich glaub hier ist kein Bitlocker dabei ne. Kennste hier mal den Unterschied? Ich bin
Windows Version aus. Ich glaub der größte Unterschied zwischen Home und Pro ist, dass
in Pro Bitlocker dabei ist und in Home nicht. Oder? Wenns da verschieben geht auch nicht.
Übrigens fällt euch mal auf, dass der Windows 10 Installer sich optisch überhaupt nicht
mehr deckt mit der Optik von Windows 10. Die sieht total anders aus. Fail. Was? Moment.
In Pro kann man Remote Desktop machen. Heißt das etwa, dass man in einer nicht Pro Windows
Version allen Ernstes keinen Remote Desktop machen kann? Was ist mit Microsoft los ey?
Sind die doch ganz bei Sinn oder? Nicht zugewiesen. Hoffentlich reicht der Speicherplatz. Ha.
Oho. Hat grad so gereicht. Ok. Windows. Mach dein Ding. Wir programmieren jetzt weiter.
Ich guck da. Mal gucken ungefähr wie schnell das geht. Na das geht doch eigentlich. Ich
meine man darf ja auch nicht vergessen. Es ist von SSD auf SSD in der VM. Also das muss
eigentlich schneller gehen als auf dem Rechner selbst. Achso man kann sich nur auf den Windows
Pro per Remote Desktop verbinden. Das ist auch schon wieder total beknackt ne. Dass es
überhaupt diese Beschränkungen wieder gibt bei Microsoft. Bitte im Audit Modus testen
mit der Aktivierung. Was ist der Audit Modus? Welche Erzde Platte läuft ja? Das ist Random
Playlist. Das ist hier Random Erzde Playlist von mir. Also das ist jetzt Dings hier Planet
Punk. Oder nicht Planet Punk. Planet Punk. Guck mal das geht doch richtig schnell Windows
Installationen. Control Shift F3 drücken wir dann nach der Sprache. Was macht denn der
Audit Modus? Ich hab keinen Schimmer von Windows. Außer dass ich Windows benutze. Die Musik
lautstärke eigentlich in Ordnung. Ich hab es jetzt mal nicht so laut gemacht wie sonst
weil ich weiß nicht ob die Erzde unbedingt jedermanns Fall sind hier. Guck mal easy.
Windows Installation fertig. Krass. Geht ja mega schnell. Kannste Programme installieren
ohne den Benutzer. Ich will doch Benutzer anlegen. Ich will den Benutzer anlegen und
gucken ob der richtig übertragen wird. Wow was ist das da unten? Wir machen mal kurz
groß. So. Fullscreen Windows VM. Das ist jetzt Windows 7 extremer. Vor allem da ist
das Oktober Update schon dabei. So macht man das aber bei Hardware Rat mit der Installation
Aktivierung. Das ist natürlich ne Sache. Wenn das so ist müssen wir das so ausprobieren.
Sagen wir mal wann ich das klicken muss. Was sagst du? Control Shift F3 wenn er nach der
Sprache fragt. Okay. Wann fragt er denn nach der Sprache? Oder war das schon? Muss ich
das Ganze jetzt nochmal machen? Oktober Update RTX on. Poggers RTX. Also ich muss jetzt mal,
ich hab's ja auf Twitter schon geschrieben Nvidia Grafiker. Also wenn ich hier überlege
dass eine RTX 280Ti ungefähr das doppelte kostet. Sagen wir mal drei Viertel bis das
doppelte. Also ich kann nicht rechnen aber ihr wisst was ich meine. Also so 80-100% mehr
als ne 1080Ti muss ich sagen. Der Leistungssprung um 30% ist finde ich nicht gerechtfertigt
bei einem fast doppelt so hohen Preis. Und ich meine mal ganz ehrlich. RTX on. Ist denen
nichts besseres eingefallen. Kennt ihr dieses komische Video von Nvidia da? RTX on. Warte
mal. Während Windaus im Hintergrund sein Zeug rumspackt. Ich mein. Ich mein. Warte mal
wenn sie das Auto explodieren lassen. Das ist. Warte mal wo lassen sie das Auto explodieren.
Hier. Hier. Kommt mal. Also. Hier zeigen sie uns ok hier ist ein Auto und hinter dem
Auto explodiert jetzt gleich was. Oh my god. So jetzt machen sie gleich die komische Explosion.
Bringen sie es ihnen super. Super amazed hier im Hintergrund. Achtung das müsst ihr euch
jetzt mal anhören. Das war Bela mal kurz muten. Passt mal. Passt mal auf jetzt wie sie ausflippen.
Ultrakomplex Surface. Also man muss sagen. Um es mal gar nicht schlecht zu reden. Reflektion
realistischer zu machen ist schon ganz nice. Aber. Aber ich meine das sieht das sieht schon
cool aus. Wie performant das läuft für was anderes. Aber die Sache ist ja nur mal die.
Es ist. Es ist für mich absolut unverständlich. Warum man das nicht auch so machen kann. Also.
Ich meine der Explosion spiegeln lassen auf der Oberfläche. Ich meine. Warum geht das
nur mit Raytracing. Das erschließt sich mir aus der Sache überhaupt nicht. Wenn man das
programmiert in seinem Spiel geht das selbstverständlich auch ohne Raytracing. Das hat auch damit
überhaupt nichts zu tun. Fake Hype Intensifies.
Ja ja gut. Ich wollte es ja nur so anzeigen. Also.
Ich bin Cortana und ich bin hier um dich zu unterstützen. Eine Anmeldung hier. Etwas WLAN
da und schon ist dein PC betriebsklar. Verwende deine Stimme oder die Taktatur. Wenn ich still
sein soll wähle einfach das kleine Mikrofon Symbol am unteren Bildschirmrand aus. Wenn
du zur Unterstützung eine Sprache ausdrückst. Cortana hat mich erschreckt. Wir drücken
jetzt Strg und Eingabe. Kann man Cortana nicht sagen dass Cortana ruhig sein soll. Das müssen
wir jetzt mal gucken. Ja Cortana lass uns loslegen. Auf gehts. Ah und was muss ich
jetzt drücken. Control Alt und F3 hast du gesagt. Ne was muss ich drücken. Warte mal
ich scroll noch mal hoch. Control Shift F3. Control Shift F3. Da passiert was.
Es rebooted. RIP vor allem. Ah ne es bewegt sich noch.
Ah wieder Musik an. Jetzt Cortana vielleicht ruhig. Ich muss halt irgendwie Sachen drauf
kopieren können weil ich hab halt nix im Installer drin. Im Gegensatz zu euch. Administrator
einen Moment bitte. Aber es ist gut zu wissen dass wenn man das drückt dass man sich nicht
durch diesen ganzen Cortana Mist durchklicken muss. Weil das wäre jetzt gefühlt 10 Minuten
gegangen. Hallo was wird heute gemacht. Mach mal Ausrufezeichen hrtool dann kommt die Erklärung.
Was war das daneben. Jetzt ist es weg. Was tut es denn. Muss ich jetzt irgendwas machen.
Ok wir installieren jetzt erstmal vor Ember Tools. Ne erstmal Leute erstmal mal ein Snapshot.
Man weiß nie was hier passiert. Wir installieren erstmal vor Ember Tools das ich Zeug drauf
kopieren kann. 800 mal 600 ich glaube wir können jetzt auch schon höher einstellen.
Ne warte mal wo geht denn das nochmal. Anzeige Einstellung. Halt das ist wieder so eklig.
Ah. Vor Ember Tools. Jaja installieren wir mal. Sollen wir mal gucken ob Netzwerk funktioniert.
Die Windows sind da vor Ember Ruckel. Läuft man manjaro aber besser. Ok Netzwerk geht.
Fertig nice. Nein wir wollen nicht neu starten. Guck mal jetzt läuft es auch hier wieder relativ
schnell. Ach ist das das neue Windows das Oktober Windows Update. Das gucken wir uns
vor allem am eigenen Stream an was es da Neues gibt. Hier wird jetzt erstmal der ganze Mist
von Microsoft nachgeladen. Systemvorbereitung kann ich zumachen. Ok. Gut. Ähm machen wir
nochmal ein Snapshot. Snapshot hier mit vor Ember Tools und löschen wir wieder. Und
dann können wir nämlich mal ausprobieren ob der Kram funktioniert. Ne das ist das falsche
Git. Das ist das aktuelle Tool ist noch nicht im Git. Ok nice. Gut wir sagen Proc können
wir mal weiter. Also wir sind gestern stehen geblieben. Schauen wir uns das ganze nochmal
an. Oh Moment wir haben das falsche Projekt aktiviert. Wir müssen nicht Koggas starten
wir müssen Progas starten. Was Koggas? Progas? Progas muss man starten. Progas ist das Web
Interface. Ok wir sind hier relativ billig gestartet. Wir machen die Seite jetzt erst
mal ein bisschen hübscher. Ähm wir machen dann eine eigene CSS Seite. Dass es ein bisschen
was her macht. CSS. Wo ist es? Da. Styles. So dann kopieren wir jetzt den ganzen Krämpel
von hier rüber. Weg damit. Zack. Der Image. Sonst war es. Blah. Wow. Achso. Ich habe
das ja noch gar nicht hinzugefügt. Lull. Link. Styles. Gut wir machen jetzt ein paar
basic Styles da rein dass es nicht mehr ganz so hässlich aussieht. Also wir kopieren
uns jetzt mal aus dem Meme Tool mal das Farbschema. Weil das sieht eigentlich ganz hübsch aus.
Das ist doch schon. Ja da. So. Blablabla. Ähm. Warum ist das so groß hier? Ach. Weg
damit. Nee wir lassen das mal alles leid ziehen. In dem Fall kommt es ja nicht so sehr auf die
Optik an. Wie nennen wir das überhaupt? Egal wie wir es nennen. Wir müssen bloß Body
die passende Klasse geben. Ok passt. So. Und dann sagen wir jetzt mal einen Button. Machen
wir mal den Button schön. Button. Border 0. Border Radius. Wir machen ein bisschen gebogen.
Die Höhe machen wir irgendwie 30 Pixel. Und Background Color. Und jetzt kommt CSS Variable.
Das ist eigentlich ganz cool. Wusste ich vorher auch nicht dass es das gibt. Bevor ich mich
hier in letzter Zeit mal ein bisschen mehr mit CSS Graben beschäftigt hab. Hier kann
man jetzt sagen. Nee warte mal. War. Und hier kann man jetzt sagen was man machen will.
Zum Beispiel irgendwie Orange oder so. Und wenn man jetzt refresht ist der Knopf ordentlich
gestylt und Orange. Das ist wirklich sehr sehr nice. So. Solution Explorer. Kann man
den irgendwie anhängen. So. Wir kopieren uns jetzt die Index Seite ein paar mal. Und
zwar. Weil ne. Vorher machen wir noch mal was anderes. Kann ich das nicht löschen.
Kann ich das nur löschen wenn ich das stoppe. So. Der ist ein Orangener Knopf. Richtig.
Was er macht ist erstmal egal. Hauptsache er ist Orange. Ähm. Ist der Broggers ein APS
ne. Ja. Ja. Ja. Das ist ASP.NET Core. Das Core ist wichtig. So. Also. Das wird unser
Navigationsminut. Das muss er jetzt ein bisschen schön machen. Hier geht man auf Index. Hier
geht man auf. Ähm. Logs. Und hier geht man auf. Das können wir nachher noch als Razor
Views machen. Dass es so ein bisschen. Bisschen drum herum gespart ist. Aber ich kopier mir
jetzt einfach mal das HTML. So. Und dann brauchen wir noch Stats. So von der Idee her. Hier
sind die Keys drinne. Hier ist die History drinne. Also sprich äh. Welche Keys benutzt
den und wann. Und hier gibts. Keine Ahnung. Hier machen wir ein paar hübsche Graphen.
Da können wir uns ein bisschen austoben. So. Class. Ähm. Haben wir irgendwelche. Ja.
Tab. Class. Oh es gibt jetzt Leute. Ich hab jetzt gesehen. Es gibt jetzt in Wishful Studio.
Passt mal auf. Es gibt irgendwie. Wie ging. Wie ging das. Ähm. Alt. Control. Guck mal
man kann jetzt Multiple Cursor machen in. In Wishful Studio. Ist jetzt neu. Ah. Schon
ist kaputt. Bäm. Lull. Schon ist kaputt. Aber ist trotzdem ganz nice oder? Ja. Ja.
So. Und da machen wir jetzt irgendwie sowas wie äh. Tab. Das ist ein bisschen hübscher
aussieht. Die Navigationsbuttons die wir hier oben haben. Starten wir mal. So Tab. Die
Dinger kriegen jetzt mal. Ähm. Erstmal kriegen die ein bisschen Platz drum herum. Oder war
es Padding? Ich kann das immer nicht merken. Der Unterschied zwischen Padding und. Das
guck. Ich guck mir das. Also ich denk mir das grad nicht aus. Ich guck mir das vom
Minboard ab. Ah. Sieht schon ein bisschen besser aus. Color. War. Ah. Das ist keine
gute Farbe dafür. Oder? So was können wir denn hier. Machen wir mal weiß. Äh schwarz.
Ja. Lull. Wird ein weißer Knopf angezeigt. Schon wird Null Null Null. Wird zu weiß.
So. Dann haben wir noch mal Break da drin. Oben drüber. Was ist Padding? Padding. Margin
ist außenrum. Okay. Das heißt dann haben wir nach oben mehr Platz. Ne. Aber haben wir
nach oben nicht mehr Platz. Ich mein wir können ja auch mal eine Break dazwischen machen. Wisst
ihr ich bin nicht so der HTML JavaScript Held. Boah so ist das auch okay. So und dann machen
wir noch was ähm. Sierra Fox heute ist alles rassistisch im Zweifelsfall. Wenn es. Es
muss ja der falsche hören. Guck mal wie das blau aussieht. Mein links sind blau. Das ist
eigentlich ganz nett. Ja. So und jetzt waren wir. Achso geht überhaupt nicht. Falsches
blau. Oh. Das sah ganz nett aus. So und jetzt waren wir. Krieg 17. Das Tab was active ist
kriegt unten drunter. Kriegt unten drunter nen Rahmen. Gucken ob das wie das so aussieht.
Lass mal sehen auf welcher Seite. Der sieht scheiße aus. Das war schon. Was machen wir
irgendwie. Keine Ahnung. Design damit habe ich es ja. Ja ja okay. Das reicht jetzt das
war okay so oder. Wieso benutzt du Bootstrap. Weil. Keine Ahnung. Weil wir das selbst machen.
Ich weiß so sieht das doch ganz okay aus. Aber das war umgedreht. Wie sieht das hier
mit blau aus. Das ist doch hübsch. Das ist doch ganz hübsch. Finde ich eigentlich ganz
gut so. Tickenschmaler oder. Keine Ahnung. Wir lassen es jetzt erstmal so. So Tab. Gut
dann können wir jetzt den Index mal kopieren. Zwar brauchen wir jetzt noch. Muss man das
umbenennen. Rename. Rename. Ach das geht ja wieder nicht wenn es läuft. Rename. Stats.
Rename. Logs. Sollten es die Seiten zumindest schon geben. Ja nice. Logs. Stats. Falsch.
Ja. Wenn ich es jetzt noch richtig machen würde. Dann würde es auch funktionieren.
So. Okay jetzt können wir jetzt haben wir sowas wie eine Navigationsleiste. Sowas in
der Richtung. Das muss jetzt erstmal reichen. So und jetzt müssen wir das ein bisschen
interaktiver machen. Und zwar will ich das. Dass das hier Disabled ist. Also das Text
fällt. Soll. Soll Disabled sein. Read Only. Read Only und Disabled. Ne muss man. Ach
da muss man irgendwas reinschreiben. Da muss man reinschreiben. Disabled. Disabled. Disabled
ist auch so eine Ausgeburt von HTML wo man sich wieder denkt the fuck. Ah ja wenn man
das jetzt noch im richtigen. Im richtigen macht weil man alles nicht kopiert hat. Dann
klappt es auch. Okay nice. So und ich will es jetzt so machen wenn ich hier auf edit
klicke dann wird es editierbar. Und dann können wir posten. Nur Disabled oder Read Only das
können wir mal gleich ausprobieren. Ich lösche die Logs und Stats Seiten nochmal. Wir machen
jetzt erstmal die Indexseite fertig und müssen auf View einbinden. Hab ich gerade Index gelöscht?
Ah fuck. Ist das jetzt im Papierkorb? Index. 1516 ja. Da ist wieder. Vorgass. Moment.
Falsches Projekt. Hier ist es wieder. Logs weg. Stats weg. So und jetzt kommt noch View
rein. Script. So und das kopieren wir uns jetzt. Das kopiere ich mir aus dem Memeboard
raus. Eigentlich ganz affach. Weil wir müssen es ja ein bisschen interaktiver machen. Das
muss ja ab und zu mal refreshen ob es neue Keys gibt und sowas. Das können wir so lassen
es passt. Ich hab da schon was vorbereitet. Mounted. Genau. Also von der Idee her müssen
wir jetzt. Ja jetzt ist es schon verkackt. Moment. Das ergibt ja überhaupt keinen Sinn
was ich hier mache. Wir müssen erstmal einen Diff reinhauen was App heißt. Weil View sucht
das ganze. Und da kommt der ganze andere Schmodder rein. Genau. So. Blablabla Keys Auto Update.
Jetzt gucken wir mal ob es funktioniert. Oder ob es eine Fehlermeldung schmeißt. What. Habe
ich falsch gemacht. Wo ist hier zu viel. Irgendwo ist ein Komma zu viel. Wo ist das
Problem hier. Ah. Ok wunderbar funktioniert. So jetzt brauchen wir Mounted. Das ist das
was View ausführt wenn es geladen wird. Und da müssen wir jetzt Keys abrufen. Und nach
dem wir diesmal kein Signal Air oder sonst was am Start haben. Machen wir jetzt die ganz
billige Javascript Variante. Wir rufen einfach einmal in der Sekunde alle unverbrauchten
Keys ab. Das heisst dazu brauchen wir noch eine Methode die. Nennen wir irgendwie Get
Keys. So und in Get Keys machen wir einen Fetch von der Idee her. Machen wir einen Fetch
und rufen von. Wie habe ich es hier genannt. Key Controller. Rufen von hier alle Keys ab.
Was. Gab es mal eine Zeit in der du hauptberuflich YouTube gemacht hast. Nein. Oder mehr verdient
das als in deinem eigenen Job. Also als ich mal wirklich richtig viel gemacht habe. Und
auch Sellout, G2A, Elgato, Nvidia alles gemacht habe. Hab ich ungefähr so viel verdient mit
YouTube wie in meinem anderen Job. Aber mittlerweile verdiene ich in meinem anderen Job im Tinken
mehr als früher und mit YouTube viel weniger weil ich nichts mache. Selbstschuld. Das ist
ein eindeutiger Fall von Selbstschuld. So wir gucken jetzt mal in die Datenbank ob wir
da noch was drin stehen hatten von gestern. Nope keine Keys. Müssen wir gleich noch einfügen.
Aber von der Idee her wir machen jetzt dann wir machen das Async. Wir haben schon Datenfelder
für Keys und für Edit und Auto Update. Gut das ich das vorher schon mal ausprobiert habe.
So jetzt müssen wir jetzt müssen wir die ganzen Keys die es noch gibt vom Server abrufen.
Wieso hast du die Lust an YouTube verloren? Ich hab gar nicht so wirklich die Lust an
YouTube verloren. Mir geht YouTube als Plattform übelst auf den Sack. Dementsprechend will
ich mich da eigentlich gar nicht mehr großartig aufhalten gerade. Obbei es wieder besser
wird. Weil ich einfach komplett YouTube Deutschland ignoriere. So wir müssen jetzt mal ein Fetch.
Await Fetch. So und jetzt müssen wir quasi Fetchen von slash api slash keys. Das ist
der api keys Controller. Ohne Argumente hinten dran ruft er das Get auf. Api Fetch, api Keys
und jetzt muss man sagen wir brauchen noch ein paar Sachen. Wir müssen nämlich noch
angeben method get. Wobei müssen wir gar nicht angeben oder. Ich glaube get macht
er standardmäßig. Dann lassen wir es mal weg. Okay. Response. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay.
Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay.
Das war's für heute.
Willkommen im Rostarm.
makerice.
willkommen im Rostarm.
mentor.
Das war's für heute.
Das war jetzt in dem else Zweig, dann will ich sagen, ich möchte editieren.
Wenn ich die Form editieren kann, dann möchte ich saifen und zum Server schicken.
so und ich habe jetzt gelesen man kann also mit mit so klassischem
jQuery würde ich jetzt hier irgendwie sagen gibt mir die form oder oder
document get element by id irgendwie form so das ist natürlich nicht im sinne
von von vue chairs weil das zu zu herkömmliches java script ist oder so
keine ahnung deswegen habe ich letztens gelesen man kann man kann das auch so
machen guck man sagt hier reff oder reffs
reffs war es
reffs und da gibt man jetzt hier name ein irgendwie form und jetzt kann man
quasi direkt drauf zugreifen aus aus view ich muss erst mal muss mal nach
gucken wie das wie das funktioniert hat
reff haben wir jetzt vielleicht noch irgendwie mal ein ordentliches beispiel
access in reff ja genau so ging das
jetzt kann er form und dann start mit direkt von der form so und jetzt sollte
das eigentlich funktionieren
ah es ist doch reffs doch nur reff
es funktioniert was gesehen ich klicke jetzt rein darf ich
editieren und wenn man dann und wenn man dann
saved und jetzt jetzt wenn man quasi aus dem edit wieder raus geht dann save da
oder auch nicht doch macht er nice guck hat er gespeichert
das ganz cool
so von der idee her müsste es jetzt eigentlich passen habe ich dir jetzt
gucken wir mal im sql browser ob da graben auf dem server angekommen ist ja
da sind die ganzen keys drinnen ganzen fake keys auch mit richtigem datum und
alles so und jetzt machen wir noch mal was ekliges und zwar weil wir hier keine
keine informationen haben wann denn neue keys oder wir kriegen keine
informationen vom server wenn sich was geändert hat oder wenn jemand in einem
anderen browser keys submitted oder so wir werden einfach jetzt ganz billig
machen wenn ihr da eine schönere idee habt außer dass wir jetzt halt wieder
wieder signal er oder irgendwas für echtzeit kommunikation da verwenden wir
machen jetzt einfach eine schleife in der wir alle sekunde abfragen ob es neue
keys gibt
jede sekunde neue keys abrufen fertig
funktioniert das jetzt ja er ruft jetzt jede sekunde wie lange filmst du heute
ich würde sagen bis das fertig ist oder bis es zumindest in der in der form ist
dass sie das mal ausprobieren können morgen ist montag da sind sie
wahrscheinlich wieder am schaffen da können sie ja mal ausprobieren ob das
ob das so funktioniert wie wir uns das gedacht haben so er ruft jetzt die keys
aber die keys noch in das textfeld reinschreiben die machen wir das jetzt
am besten get keys so hier haben wir die ganzen keys drinne hier haben wir die
ganzen keys drinne das heißt wir unser textfeld unser textfeld kriegt als als
model also sprich da wo sie daten drin schreibt das keysfeld ich meine da ist
aktuell noch nichts drinne ob es funktioniert können wir einfach mal so
testen wir hier was reinschreiben ja funktioniert so und jetzt müssen wir die
keys hier reinschreiben und zwar jedes mal jedes mal wenn wir keys bekommen
müssen wir uns da jetzt die richtigen keys raus filtern weil das problem ist
ja ich zeige sie noch mal das ist ja sind ja nicht nur keys das sind ja da
sind ja komplett alle informationen die wir haben also sprich wann es erstellt
wurde wann es benutzt wurde und was das brauchen wir an der stelle gar nicht
wir brauchen eigentlich jetzt nur die keys aus diesem error kann man kann man
sowas machen mal gucken ob das funktioniert
map und dann sagen wir irgendwie item item und daraus wollen wir jetzt den key
und den schreiben wir in keys ich gehe mal davon aus dass wir so nicht
funktionieren weil java script der meinung ist das geht mit dem
not not used remove range unused leistung so als kommen nämlich mal ein
bisschen bisschen löschen da sieht man aber auch schon das ding
liegt auch noch halbwegs schnell mit 6000 lizenzen drin ich glaube 6000
lizenzen werden sie da nicht drinne haben löschen
oh es ist abgekackt warum ist es abgekackt
ah moment haha also die redirecten jetzt erst mal wieder auf den index und dann
müssen wir natürlich noch den kontext speichern haben wir ganz vergessen und
hier unten in die directen wir auch
okay das kommt man selbst funktioniert
löschen
wo der ok da ist ein bisschen beschäftigt wenn 6000 keys löscht aber
kies sind alle weg funktioniert schon mal
als duplizieren funktioniert nicht immer noch
wie viel wie viel kies sind das jetzt
kann man sich rein pesten
ich kann ich kann ich darf das nicht kopieren
warum darf ich das nicht kopieren ist es ist es zu viel oder was darf ich so viel
nicht copy pasten 3000 ok so viel werden sie nie drinne haben an
use keys so löschen wir den krempel mal zack alle weg
den dschungel zerstören das ozomloch geht mir am arst vorbei
doch überall verfolgt nicht euer liege zeigen meine armen ohren sie können sich
nicht wehren ich höre längst kein radio mehr und seh auch nicht fern doch als
retter der welt liegt ihr vorm rennen ihr malträtiert euer instrument und ihr
machen jetzt noch was wir sagen wir wollen bloß noch nämlich die idee wir
wollen bloß noch die kies haben aber wir machen das jetzt mal richtig schön
wir wollen jetzt nur noch die kies haben die einzeln sind wir hatten doch
letztendlich letztens war das thema
wie man aus einer liste doppelte einträge löschen kann so ganz einfach
hier wirft er alle doppelten einträge raus so also von der idee was uns jetzt
natürlich passieren kann ist also sprich wenn ich nichts pushe ist gut dann
dann will ich alles an juste löschen das ergibt irgendwie sinn allerdings ich
will nicht alles doppelt und dreifach einfügen
gucken was jetzt passiert wenn ich jetzt die gleichen kies einfüge
ja da speichert es noch doppelt und dreifach das ist natürlich blöd warum
speichert es noch doppelt und dreifach
weil ja klar weil er sich immer nur die gepushten anguckt die die kies die er
pusht und nicht die die da schon in der datenbank drinnen hat das heißt wir
machen das ist mir ein bisschen zu lang hier ich habe eine idee was man das
müsste eigentlich ganz gut funktionieren wir speichern uns das jemals
unikis weiß nicht kies ist das stimmt ja nicht
es sind ja leistens sollten wir das auch ordentlich benennen
rename das mag ich auch in brüssel studio dass das so einfach geht
unik leistens ist moment das habe ich doppelt benannt na geil
und in dem fall in dem fall ist das ist das weder noch was mache ich da nicht
für blödsinn in dem fall ist es gar nichts in dem fall ist das der input der
input den ich gepusht kriege das heißt sie sind noch nicht mal klar ob es
leistensins oder kiesin nennen wir es mal input sind einfach leins unik leins
sind das trifft eigentlich am ehesten
so und hier ist es nicht key ist es lein
oh nee kinder gibt nichts nervigeres als kinder
du hast anius in der variabler falsch geschrieben echt
an suit er wurde noch nicht verklagt anzeige ist raus ja
so unik leins bla bla bla so und jetzt von der theorie hier jetzt gucke ich
hier nicht nur ob er regex mehr sondern ich schaue ob das was ich quasi
einfügen will nicht schon hier drinne ist und da können wir einfach sagen an
just leistensens any und dann gucken wir leistens key gleich wenn es nicht da
drinne ist wenn es nicht da drinne ist und der regex match dann was hinzufügen
also von der idee her ich weiß nicht ob es funktioniert dass wir gleich mal
gucken also von der idee her würde ich sagen
der splittet hier die die gepushten lizenz keys also rein der text macht eine
schleife drüber dann guckt da ob ein key den ich hinzufügen will nicht
zufällig schon drinne ist da wollen wir nicht wieder hinzufügen
ja
es müsste eigentlich funktionieren
so probieren wir das mal aus
oh nee ich brauche wieder willows key wenn ich brauche willows key ss service
hier
ok das sollte nicht funktionieren also den sollte jetzt rausschmeißen
oder von der idee her ja wunderbar sehr schön
big brain guck und er speichert jetzt den mist auch nicht mehr also sprich wenn ich
selbst wenn ich den kanzel doppelt hier reinpaste speichert er jeweils nur noch
ein so muss das sein jetzt ist die frage können wir schon was
lauschen ich glaube das geht nicht es ist eigentlich ein fall der kommt nicht
vorne eigentlich sollte man das nicht löschen können aber es könnte ja sein
dass dass die jungs jetzt sagen hell wir haben diesen key hier von hand genommen
und aktiviert wir müssen ihn entfernen könnte immer noch sein und das
funktioniert nämlich schon nicht so das heißt wenn wir hier durch sind
müssen wir abschließend auch gucken ob es keys gibt jetzt quasi unbenutzt sind
also wenn wir es mal removed
und da muss man jetzt mal ein bisschen den den den kopf zerbiegen
zerbrechen ist hier hirnserbiegen wie auch immer wie wir das am besten raus
kriegen wirst du dafür eigentlich bezahlt oder machst du das vor 3 ich
mache das komplett umsonst hauptsächlich aus dem grund dass ich
kann und das ist relativ überschaubares projekt
außerdem finde ich geil was er mit seinem shop macht die meisten leute
das finde ich das bei ihm auch cool die meisten leute labert immer nur rum so
nach dem motto wir müssen hier irgendwas machen und am schlimmsten sind sind
dann die leute die sich drüber beschweren so nach dem motto irgendjemand
anderes hat was gemacht das funktioniert dann sind sie am meckern so nach dem
motto alter ach was hat er schon gemacht hätte ich auch machen können haben
sie aber nicht das finde ich war hat eigentlich ganz cool da hat es gesagt
ich kenne mich mit der geschichte aus ich habe zeit aber die geld für hat
weil ich nicht aber scheint er zu funktionieren und er macht das einfach
und ich denke das kann man auch mal unterstützen ich finde das gut dass er
das macht als wenn das ist echt nice wie er das mit seinem job managt so von
von nichts zu was quasi
und wenn ihm das tool hilft dabei ist doch ist doch super
und ich höre schon die ersten leute dann wieder rum merken so nach dem motto
was ist da schon dabei hat einfach ein hardware shop bla bla bla so nach dem
motto um das um das schlecht zu reden so kann doch jeder aber kann eben nicht
jeder wenn es jeder könnte warum macht es dann nicht jeder weil sie entweder zu faul
sind es doch nicht können oder kein bock haben und er macht es klappt ob es
langfristig klappt muss ich raus stellen werden wir noch sehen aber ich finde es
auf jeden fall cool deswegen kann mir eben der helfen bei
eventuell ausgeben lassen wie viele doppelte keys vorhanden sind können wir
noch machen ja so ich muss jetzt erst mal überlegen wie kriege ich jetzt aus
mir tut die zunge wie jetzt mit dem zahl ist wirklich nervig wie kriege ich jetzt
raus ob wir lizenzen haben die entf also ob man eine lizenz entfernen können wir
können die origine lizenz entfernen wenn in anjust anjust leisen das wenn dort
die leisenz nirgends wo hier drinne ist also sprich ich nehme ja alle lizenzen
und gucke ob sie in dem input drin sind der gepusht wurde sind sie nicht in dem
input drin die gepusht wurde bedeutet dass sie wurden entfernt und ich kann
sie löschen ich hoffe das funktioniert so das wird
jetzt ein bisschen in jeglicher unic lines jetzt haben wir lines und lines
keine ahnung wenn wir das mal hier
kommen wir denn das ist u
hier not so und das müsste mir jetzt von der idee manchmal ist link schon ganz
cool das müsste mir jetzt alle sachen geben die man pushen entfernt wurden
so das haben wir remove range mal gucken ob das funktioniert context remove
range
save okay mal gucken ob das jetzt klappt
kann kennt sich irgendwer mit kopfhörer mikrofon was willst du ein mikrofon und
kopfhörer oder willst du ein headset also wenn du kopfhörer also wenn du
richtiges mikro fällst den kopf und den kopfhörer also der geheimtipp ist er
immer noch bei den kopfhörern für kleines geld die superlux dinger
gut funktioniert nice doppeltes zeug hinzufügen geht nicht
4 5 funktioniert und es löschen wir mal irgendwas geht auch nice nice nice
ok passt fertig das mit dem split on klein könnte man vielleicht trotzdem noch
irgendwann machen ok also ich würde sagen so die verwaltung für kies kommen
jetzt erst mal so lassen das war es vorhin ich weiß nicht mehr wie er hieß
gesagt hat gabi rally das baue ich da muss mir noch ein bisschen gedanken zu
machen über das machen können dass man noch kommentare hinzufügen
damit brauchen wir irgendwie den import button
ok
gut jetzt müssen wir mal testen wie das ob das aktivieren funktioniert
also beziehungsweise unsern unsern kleinte eigentlich aktivieren soll
such for keys also wo sind wir denn hier stehen geblieben
die lied ah das ist war übrigens auch falsch ist mir eingefallen
wir wollen die lizenz wenn wir sagen die liet wollen wir nicht wirklich die
lieten sondern wir wollen das ist auch nicht geben
wir wollen die lizenz wollen wir auf used setzen und zwar jetzt gerade wurde die
benutzt das kann man nämlich später eine auswertung ordentlich einführen
jetzt sagen wir nicht remove sondern einfach safe
was hast du verpasst wir haben noch nicht allzu lang angefangen die
keyverwaltung geht jetzt also wir aktivieren jetzt mal
leistens ok guck mal ob das theoretisch funktioniert activate yes er hat es
entfernt guckt 245 wir gehen mit dem sq light explorer dran
warum löscht er noch das soll nicht mal löschen sich verschrieben
warte mal jetzt ok der key verschwindet
ich glaube ich muss das ding mal starten neu ich habe das ich habe das
nicht neu gestartet seitdem ich das hier auf umgestellt habe
hier fügen wir noch mal ein paar fake windows keys hinzu
gut die reinfalle ist da scheiß egal erst mal sie sieht nicht schön aus aber
windows keys in irrandom ja das da müssen wir uns noch ein
bisschen was schöneres überlegen zu
kann man die freshen ja so und jetzt starten aktiviert jetzt
funktioniert war mein was irgendwas habe ich verkehrt gemacht
ah nee hat funktioniert jetzt hat er den key gesetzt auf used also sprich wenn
es aktivieren geklappt hat von der windows lizenz dann setzt er die zeit
wenn es aktiviert wurde dass ich habe hier ein fehler in meinem filter drille
ja siehst du wir wollen nämlich wer wo es nicht just ist nur die lizenzen die
nicht just sind ok
jetzt gucken wir noch mal was funktioniert
so aktivieren yes
ich habe nicht zugeschaut ist kann key verschwunden kann key verschwunden oder
nicht yes ja nice key ist weg ok das funktioniert
wir müssen wir ordentlich ausmaß search for key server
key found so und da schreibe es ein license info key genau da zeigt er
nämlich noch mal den key an und jetzt kann man sagen activate yes no read key
pressed key wenn der key
wie oft das wort key wenn der key gleich yes ist dann machen wir weiter
so und hier windows akkrivaten an der stelle
hier sind wir fertig wir machen unten noch ein sleep rein dass das ding noch mal kurz
das ist zwar nicht schön aber wir machen noch mal ein sleep rein das ist einfach
noch mal kurz eine sekunde offen bleibt am ende und sich dann beendet
wenn man wenn das aktiviert haben jetzt muss alles hier rein hier müssen
windows aktiviert nachgucken aber wenn wir schon mal no gepresst haben dann
wollen wir auch gar nicht aktiviert also sprich wenn wir sagen no dann geht
er direkt raus no ok das funktioniert
so if aktivierten geklappt dann werden wir es löschen also beziehungsweise wenn
das aktivieren geklappt hat dann werden wir jetzt müssen wir erst mal raus
kriegen wie man mit sie scharf feststellen kann ob windows aktiviert
ist da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt wie das funktioniert da müssen wir stack
auf flow also man guckt mir 160 leute zu krasser scheiß
nice dass sie soviel dass so viele dabei sind ich gucke mal nicht dass ich
wieder die follows und sonstige dinger über sehe da bin ich ja bekannt für den
krampf zu übersehen aber hier steamlabs machen wir mal auf noch nicht mal auf alles steamlabs und tippy stream
ja danke für die ganzen follows ich sehe leider plus die letzten paar
frech alex und weit 3 sir holzer und teuto die anderen waren angeblich schon gestern
vielleicht gab es auch einfach nicht mehr kann auch sein schon dass ihr dabei
seid im streben wenn wir meine zunge nicht so wehtun oder ok wie können wir
checken mit sie schabt ob windows aktiviert ist stack overflow fragen programmatically check
windows 7 aktiviert die sli api was das wie soll das funktionieren
kann der du nicht mal ein beispiel schreiben
das c-script ja und wie die ärzte sind durch ja da müssen wir was anderes anmachen
da war wieder unseren 24 7 chill so stream an
ok wie genau funktioniert man das ist bestimmt in der c-api geschichte wieder
oder na das machen wir ganz bestimmt nicht da muss es da muss es eine schönere
variante geben
warum ist es unter windows alles immer so kompliziert
da kommt man hat schon einer was fertiges gebastelt
wir können uns jetzt einfach mal von ihm ab
da der endlich mal einer der seine dateien auch ordentlich benennt
was geht mir dem du ab ich will einfach nur gucken wenn es aktiviert ist
das muss anders gehen
haute check leistungs dato sind sie schabt
windows ist aktiviert
copy paste stack overflow triffen sind für heute
copy paste beste was macht er denn hier
gucken wir uns das mal an was was macht er da eigentlich
management scope
management scope management environment machine name
blubb connect
was macht er da überhaupt
kann mir das irgendjemand erklären was was genau macht er
application id in uid leisten status eins
und das soll funktionieren
gucken wir mal
ist windows aktiviert sollte uns jetzt eigentlich tru tru rauskommen
macht
macht gar nichts hängt
na geil
vielleicht ist einfach nur langsam
alles jetzt funktioniert
man braucht windows wirklich zehn sekunden um zu checken ob es aktiviert
ist
warum was ist das wieder was ist das für für für magic code wieder
ok es funktioniert anscheinend
also erstens ist es saumäßig langsam und zweitens ich habe keine ahnung was es
tut
man muss doch irgendwie ernsthaft jetzt mal ernsthaft leute man muss doch
irgendwie normal checken können ob windows aktiviert ist
der typ macht es genauso mit woher haben wir diese magic id was ist das woher
weiß man das
woher woher weiß man das
warum ist eine ducky one skyline auf weil ich zeigen wollte was für eine
tastatur geholt habe für die arbeit
also da muss es doch irgendwas schöneres geben
also gefallen tut mir das nicht aber ich meine es geht wir lassen es erst mal
so sehr overflow copy paste beste also das ist komplett magie hier oben wieder
komplett magic
want to activate windows now fragezeichen yes no
wenn aktivieren funktioniert hat das kriegen wir hier mit raus
bis windows aktiviertet dann
dann
setzen wir den key auf use und nur dann
so das müsste das müsste eigentlich unser activator programm sein bis auf
eigentlich aktivieren
search for keyserver bla bla bla da schreiben wir da schreiben wir noch
irgendwie
server info mal gucken
und ja da found key found
getting key from
wir haben den kram genannt
habe mit
Key found
Want to activate windows now, okay, yes enter
Ah der hängt jetzt, der hängt jetzt weil er Windows Aktivierung checkt. Warum dauert der Scheiß so lange Windows Aktivierung checkt?
Okay hat nicht funktioniert oder?
Doch hat funktioniert, ich gebe bloß keine Meldung aus, ich noob
Hat funktioniert, guckt es Leute, ist nur noch ein Key drin, hat funktioniert
Fügen wir mal, fügen wir mal wieder ein paar Keys ein
Ah, wir könnten übrigens den Check gegen alle Keys mal laufen lassen, weil die müssten eigentlich alle Unix sein
Ah, nice Artikel, Paddy, Pupke, allerdings ist es ja noch komplizierter
Ach nee, ah die machen das mit dieser komischen SL, RP
Geschichte
Ja, ich lasse es jetzt erst mal so ganz ehrlich
Die fünf Sekunden hat man nach dem Aktivierungsprozess auch noch übrig
So, dann geben wir jetzt irgendwie noch sowas aus wie Activation
Wir geben einfach aus, success
Success und dann sagen wir mark key as used
Fertig
Okay, search for keys that were found, get a key from, machen wir noch ein Leerzeichen rein
Alter 165, krasse Scheiße, wie viele Leute hier zukommen
Checkt überhaupt irgendjemand was ich hier mache? Also ich weiß, es gibt genug die's checken
Wer checkt nicht was ich hier mache
Woher weiß ich, ob ich eine Arraylist oder einen Array benutzen muss, ich habe keinen Plan vom Programmieren und bin mitten im 1. September, dann wird es jetzt Zeit das ganze zu lernen
Also in C sharp beziehungsweise dotnet ist es relativ einfach eine Arraylist verwendet man nicht mehr, Arraylist ist dotnet 1.0
Also java, java keine Ahnung, ne localhost wird nicht funktionieren, ja ja der schreibt die Serverurl rein die er auf der er läuft, also ich kann ihm einfach sagen er soll dort die IP einschreiben, auf die er läuft
Also ich kann ihm einfach sagen er soll dort die IP einschreiben, auf die er läuft
So, want to activate Windows now, yes, enter, ok da müssen wir noch eine Waiting oder so einplanen, klar
Success, jawoll, da waren wir jetzt hier, press any key to exit, console read key
Ok, nice, das funktioniert prinzipiell, hier müssen wir noch anzeigen, dass er das erwartet
Mein Gott, das Abfragen lange ey, das Abfragen braucht ja fast länger als das Aktivieren
Press any key to exit, nice, no
Hat das Tool eigentlich auch Raytracing, du meinst ob das RTX on enabled ist das Tool, das Tool nicht, allerdings, mein Diodexgiftplayer der kann natürlich in Zukunft auch Raytracing wozu immer man das brauchen soll
Error Handling, what, achso wobei, naja, so wirklich viele Fehler kann es an der Stelle gar nicht geben, das einzige was passieren kann ist, dass er selber nicht antwortet und dann kackts ab, was aber auch ok ist
Schauen wir mal ein Abfragen nach welcher Dienst so lange braucht, ok
Prozessexplorer auf und gucken welcher Dienst so lange braucht zum Aktivieren
Ok, machen wir das jetzt am besten, want to activate, yes, das da, SPPSVC, SPPSVC, was ist das, SPPSVC
Was ist das, Praxis Tip Chip
Und was es sich beim Winnersprozess SPPSVC handelt, ist ein Winnersdienst, der Prozess heißt bla bla bla bla bla, das Tool ist dafür zuständig Digital Lizenzen runterzuladen, na ok, der geht wahrscheinlich zu Microsoft und guckt ob das wirklich aktiviert ist das Winners
Dass man das nicht faken kann oder so
Ja und das Aktivieren werden wir jetzt folgendermaßen machen, wir faken das jetzt gerade mal, allerdings so möglichst realistisch wie es irgendwie geht und dann probieren wir es in unserer VM aus, da bin ich ja mal gespannt drauf, also machen wir hier Prozess
Ich zeige euch mal was, ich zeige euch jetzt mal wie man Atmen, oh mir tut echt die Zunge weh, das ist übelst kacke eher
Wie ihr einen Prozess starten könnt und quasi in der laufenden Anwendung für den neuen Prozess Atmenrechte anfordern könnt, und zwar müsst ihr erstmal, erstmal müsst ihr sagen hier Prozess Start Info und dann halt was, was ihr starten soll
In dem Fall starten wir einfach mal eine CMD
Und dann, das ist das Wichtige, den musste ich nämlich auch mal nachgucken bei Stack Overflow, wusste ich aus dem Kopf auch nicht, jetzt kann man sagen Verb, übelst Akarn Magic wieder, Run S, wenn man das davor schreibt, also wenn man den Run S davor schreibt, dann fragt er nach Atmenberechtigung an für den neuen Prozess, weil Windows
Gibt es auch was wie Wait, aja ja, da habe ich das Richtige für dich
So, mal gucken ob das jetzt funktioniert, want to activate Windows, ihr sehts nicht ne, aber ich habe jetzt eine admin shell, hat funktioniert und wenn die zugeht, das ist dann halt quasi das Aktivierungsding, wenn die zugeht dann checkt er
Ja wir könnten, wir könnten, ich habe eine Idee, was wir hier noch machen könnten
Wir könnten dann, hat man gehört, ok
Wir könnten wirklich noch einen Progress anzeigen, also irgendwie sowas, mal gucken wie wir das gescheit machen
Warte mal mal gucken, da muss ich jetzt mal kurz ausprobieren, ich weiß gar nicht wie wir das gescheit machen, ich versuche jetzt mal eine Progress Bar anzuzeigen
Oder wir zeigen erstmal den Status an
Und jetzt mal ganz billige Variante, mal gucken ob das funktioniert und jetzt console write Punkt
Ihr sollt ihr Punkt Punkt Punkt schreiben, bis ich
Wow, bis ich cancel auf true setze, gucken ob das klappt, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
Want to activate Windows, yes
Status Bar, krasser Shit oder, Porgas
Das ist doch cool, übrigens der, das ist, das ist der Node, das ist die Node.js Progress Bar, kennt ihr die Node.js Progress Bar, die haben irgendwie
Ich weiß nicht, wie machen wir das, mir fällt jetzt nichts anderes ein, wenn wir das machen
Guck mal ob die schöne aussieht
Was genau ich falsch gemacht, ah ich muss den Kram escaten
Ach nee Moment, das geht so nicht, wir müssen quasi ein Zeichen zurück machen oder, allen geht das wahrscheinlich
Das ist das, was ist das für ein Gefrickel hier
Hä
Ich würde gerne einen Carriage Return machen, ach scheiß drauf wir bleiben bei Punkten
Punkte reichen auch, Punkte, alle 250 Millisekunden ein Punkt und gut ist
Müsste, müsste B sein, ok
War das nicht B, jedoch kann, kann sein
Mach einen Flug, oh Emojis, jawoll, kann eigentlich die Windows Kommando Zeile mittlerweile Emojis
Alter guck mal wie lange der Scheiß dauert ey
Wahrscheinlich bin ich jetzt schon bei Microsoft geplockt, weil ich so oft anfrage
Tauke einmal auf, ach nee, weil ich die Shell nicht zumache
Kann die Windows Shell Emojis, nee, oh sind wir rückständig Microsoft
Microsoft ist auch zu rückständig was das angeht
Kann das das Power Shell Fenster
Nee
Das ist aber ganz ganz schlecht
Kann Bash Emojis sein, na Bash muss, Bash ist die Shell
Die kann alle möglichen Zeichen die du ergibst, ob dein Terminal Emojis kann ja und die meisten Terminals können mittlerweile noch die Linux Emojis
Meint ihr an der Schriftart links, können wir mal ausprobieren
Font
Sieguedingsbums, nee
Ist ja was scheiß auf Emojis, wir mal gucken was passiert wenn ich sie reinschreibe
Nee guck, der kanns nicht
Fail
Microsoft Fail
Display Emojis, wie geht das, ich will wissen wie das geht
Das ist doch nicht live, guck mal, wenn die am 18.07. vielleicht kommt das mit dem Oktober Update
Ja mit dem Oktober Update geht das wahrscheinlich
Wenn es quasi im Juni in Insider Builds war da ist es wahrscheinlich im Oktober Update dabei
Progers
Dann probieren wir das mit dem Oktober Update nochmal aus
Aber so müssen wir uns mit Punkten
So müssen wir uns mal mit Punkten auseinandersetzen
Punkt, Punkt, Punkt, Punkt
Geht nicht, oh Scheiße
Ok, so jetzt testen wir mal das Activaten
Auf der zweiten Kiste
So wie ist denn der richtige Befehl zum Activaten überhaupt
SLMGR oder so
Thera Fox, wieso was hast du geschrieben
Wie macht man nochmal die Bildschirmtastatur auf
Wisst ihr das
Ah hier
Onscreen
Emojis, wie macht man Emojis
Wie geht das, ich hab noch nie über dieses komische Windows Ding Emojis eingefügt
Wie kommt man jetzt hier auf Emojis, Options
Windows plus Punkt ok
Doch CMD erkannt
Fast
Debated
Ok wir müssen jetzt mal ausbedenken ob das funktioniert
Ich hoffe ich deaktiviere mein Windows jetzt nicht
Deswegen schalte ich den Admin Modus mal aus
Kann man das überhaupt so ausführen
CM, so
SLMGR VBS, Official Basic Script
Official Basic Script, das ist das Schlimmste was es gibt
Ok wenn ich das so ausführe passiert ja wahrscheinlich nichts
Error
Request, Action, Requires
Elevated Privilege, ok das ist gut
Ich will ja mein Windows nicht deaktivieren
An der Stelle wollen wir jetzt natürlich nicht reinschreiben einfach so
Sondern den License Info Punkt Key brauchen wir an der Stelle
Und dann müssen wir sagen Process Start Info
Shell, use Shell
Ok er kann das ganze nicht ausführen, warum nicht
Windows warum nicht
Ah ich hab IPK vergessen
Ok Windows wo ist das Problem
Cannot find file
Also muss ich wahrscheinlich CMD
Ach du Scheiße
Stack Overflow
Run Commands and Prompt Commands
File, CMD, Argument, aha
So rum macht man das
Warum gibt es da auch immer use Shell to execute
Weil Microsoft, man weiß es nicht
Also, File, CMD, Argument
Das da, oder, ne, wat
Wie funktioniert das jetzt
Ah Moment
Windows, please
CMD
Ok was muss ich machen
C machen wir Echo 1
Ok anscheinend muss man dann Slash C dran machen
Slash C
Ok ob das so funktioniert ich weiß ja nicht
Was hat der für Schmerzen
Hey es funktioniert
Access Denied
Wie krieg ich denn von dem Exit Code von dem Prozess
Es hat doch bestimmt ein Exit Code
Exit Code, nice
Want to activate Windows, yes
Fehler, Fehler, Fehler
Exit, ok ich vermute man ein Exit Code von Minus, Blah
Also ein Exit Code umgleich Null ist wahrscheinlich auch
Unter Windows Kacke oder
Gucken wir mal Echo 1 was da rauskommt
Null, ja gut
Also Exit Code muss Null sein von dem Programm
Und Windows muss Activator danach sein
Dann passt das eigentlich
Alter 180 Leute
Wo kommen die eigentlich alle her hat mich irgendjemand gehorstet und ich hab's übersehen
Keine Horst oder sowas
Sehr nice dass ihr alle am Start seid heute
Das ist wirklich absolut massiv Coggers und Poggers und alles zusammen was es so gibt
Und vor allem sehr easy
Aus der Zukunft
200 Viewer Face Reveal
Eine Million YouTube Abos
Face Reveal
Ok jetzt probieren wir das Ganze mal auf unserer VM aus ob das funktioniert
Ok wir starten jetzt das ASP.NET Ding
Dann gehen wir hier
Bin, Debug
Coggers
Bis den ganzen Schmodder probieren wir uns jetzt mal auf unsere VM
Wo ist unsere VM hier
Bin ich mal gespannt
Nice, nice
Warum kackt es ab
Lipp
Der kackt ab weil er sich nicht zum Webserver verbinden kann
Ach Localhost Alter
Leute ich sag's noch wir müssen es ändern
Ich sag noch wir müssen es ändern
Aber
Leute
Lull
Omega Lull
Ok
Wir machen erstmal meine IP ne warte mal wie kriegt man
C-Sharp wie kriegt man die Local IP raus
Erstmal so
So machen wir das
Und das schöne daran ist man sieht jetzt schon
Man muss an dem Client nichts ändern
Also wenn ich das jetzt starte
Wenn ich das jetzt starte wird es wahrscheinlich wieder nicht funktionieren ob es ein falscher Desktop
Und ich gehe jetzt wieder zu meinem Client
Da seht ihr
Der discovert den neuen Server automatisch
Der kann sich allerdings da immer noch nicht hin verbinden
Weil
Ich ASP.NET Core nicht gesagt habe
Er soll an der externen IP lauschen
Aber das machen wir jetzt gleich
Mal gucken was passiert
Wahrscheinlich time outet der jetzt gleich
Denke ich mal
Wahrscheinlich time outet der ja genau
Das heißt ich muss erstmal als ASP.NET Core noch sagen
Binde dich mal an die externe IP
Und es gucken wir uns einfach ab
UseWorlds genau
So jetzt lauscht er an Port 5001
Sehr nice global an Port 5001
Oder auch nicht
Das hängt oder
Ah
Port 5000
Bestand 5001
Aha
Da sind wir wieder
So mal gucken ob ich vom anderen Rechner aus drauf komme
Ja komme ich
Ok und jetzt gehen wir nochmal in unsere VM und gucken ob es funktioniert
Wäre nicht lokal doch klar
Also ne die eigene IP machen wir
Gleich noch rein
So mal gucken ob jetzt das Activating funktioniert
Seht ihr? Found Key
Hat den Key vom Server abgerufen
Want to activate yes
Ja ok das Aktivieren geht jetzt natürlich nicht
Weil wir kein Key haben
Sonst könnten wir das ausprobieren wir haben keinen Key
Und wenn wir
Jetzt den Key einfügen der letrit ist ist der Key instant weg weil on stream
Oh my english sucks
I cannot stream in english
Aber prinzipiell seht ihr das funktioniert
Allerdings ist das ein bisschen fail
Mein Timer geht nicht aus
Was habe ich verkackt
Nö du brauchst nichts ins vorinstalliert
Du musst einfach nur den Server ausführen im gleichen Netz wo du ihr Clients installierst
Nehm doch den KMS das ist nicht meine Entscheidung
Ich bastle den Jungs bloß was dass sie das Leben einfacher haben
Mit dem was sie jetzt haben
Und jetzt ist der Translator am Start
Was habe ich hier kaputt gemacht cancel
Soll auf jeden Fall gecancelt werden immer
Ob das aktivieren klappt oder nicht
Zum testen echt ernsthaft was ist das für ein Key
Ist das ein trial Key oder was
Ist das ein trial Key mit dem man das ausprobieren kann
Können wir mal ausprobieren
Probieren wir mal aus
Wenn es damit zum testen geht wäre natürlich sehr nice
Das ist Slmgr Vbs-IPX
Windows Eingabe aus Vorfohlung
Warum ist das so schlecht zu benutzen
ipk ist es ipk nicht ipx ipk
ipk
Watt und das sogar ohne admin rechte aber das ist wahrscheinlich einfach nur weil es fake ist oder
Achne ich bin der admin
Nice das ist cool zum testen das wirklich cool zum testen
Aktiviert das jetzt so?
Ersetzt den vorne... ah ato ist aktivieren ah verstehe verstehe
Fehler der dns name ist nicht vorhanden was für ein dns name
Hab ich kein dns drin doch habe ich
Ok keine ahnung aber das geht wahrscheinlich nicht weil das jetzt weil das kein offizieller key ist
Start die vm mal neu ok
Aber das ist das ist trotzdem ein cooler key zum testen
Warum gucken hier 200 Leute zu was geht denn heute ab
Habt ihr habt ihr den channel so gefunden über über twitter einfach in der science
and technology kategorie oder seid ihr über youtube da oder seid über twitter da oder
200 krasser poggers twitter hier
Keiner hat was von 200 viewern cam gesagt ich hab gesagt eine million abos auf youtube dann cam
man kann man irgendwie mit diesem slm gr kann man da irgendwie checken ob wenn es aktiviert ist
xpr ablaufdatum ok also prinzipiell scheint das echt zu funktionieren was hier gebastelt hat
wir tragen jetzt mal den was ist das aus ausgemacht wir tragen das jetzt mal hier ein
alles hat jetzt als als letzter key drinnen wir löschen einfach noch mal alles das key
händling braucht noch ein bisschen verbesserung
jetzt haben wir den key hier drinnen haben wir noch ein paar fake keys wieder unten drunter
jetzt aktivieren wir den kram nochmal so wir müssen es nämlich noch auf markiert
setzen also wenn es aktiviert ist und der exit koden null dann wenn du es weg machen hier ich
mache euch da auch nur eine exit raus ihr braucht nicht den ganzen list kopieren dann beziehungsweise
ihr müsst überhaupt nicht kopieren ihr müsst einfach in eure installer einbauen
es überprüft ob es aktiviert ist und es ist nicht aktiviert weil er es halt nicht
überprüfen kann ja da kann das kann ich hier nicht nachstellen das müsst ihr morgen mal
ausprobieren ob das funktioniert
das müsst ihr nachher mal nachbauen
mal nachher ausprobieren das kann ich von hier nicht machen das kann man nur testen
mit einem wirklichen fehlenden windows key ein ato noch hinten dran ahja ok stimmt
ran erst brauchen wir nicht ne ihr lasst ja eher als admin laufen wie verbindet man mit
der window stellt zwei befehle ich meine mit best würde ich so machen command command
benutzen mal template strings damit ist das ganze ein bisschen schöner ne wir sind nicht
ja was kippt was man sie schabt template strings noch mal was vielleicht doch so das war ja
was kippt wie ist dann sie auf wie sein template string sind sie schabt noch mal aus oder war
das einfach ganz normal so ich kann es mir nicht merken ach ja denkst davor
dollar davor war das
license info key so und jetzt hinten dran kann man sowas machen einfach dass er das
nacheinander ausführt geht das probieren wir mal aus
also echo eins echo zwei ja ne ach das geht unter windows auch das ist ja nice das geht
unter windows auch das wusste ich gar nicht ja dann ist das nice ok das müsste jetzt
funktionieren das müssen wir morgen vielleicht mal ein bisschen testen ob das geht weil
das ist halt die einzige sache die ich hier bei mir nicht gescheit testen kann ja ich
habe noch meine hardcoded ip drinne die müssen wir jetzt ersetzen durch die server ip da
wie kriegt man am besten in c-sharp die eigene ip oh ist das wieder kompliziert kann man
nicht einfach sagen ip wie local oder so ich meine gut es könnte ja sein dass wir mehrere
netzwerkkarten haben dann ist nicht ganz klar welche wir nehmen müssen was ist das hier
warum ist das so warum ist das wieder so kompliziert eine lokale ip zu kriegen ob man mal was da
rauskommt jetzt ip host entry gucken wir mal wie wir das gescheit raus kriegen die lokale
ip das ist dein gift plan der gift player ist eigentlich fertig und ich habe ihn auch
schon teilweise eingebaut in das meme tool address list first kann ich einfach sagen
first und gut ist oh nee ipv6 brauchen wir in dem fall nicht ok es ist doch nicht so
einfach wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe die lokale ip rost ok address list ah da
ja ja es ist richtig das geht bestimmt die wähle ich denn jetzt aus was die beste ip
ist
kannst für die erste version auch ip dns fest reinschreiben kann ich machen
kann ich machen ja schickt mir einfach mal
irgendwo
eure ip dann
da füge ich das nachher noch ein bevor ich das nachher schicke
da lassen wir es jetzt erst mal so und wir bauen das web interface noch ein bisschen schöner
wir bauen das web interface noch ein bisschen schöner weil da fehlt ja noch ganz viel guckt mal
weil aktuell gibt es ja einfach eine key anzeige logs und stats ist noch gar nichts drin also logs
sollten wir zumindest jetzt mal machen
ok mache ich mache ich ja
ok mache ich mache ich ja logs schreiben wir noch rein was denn also sprich wer denn wie wo gejusst hat
also eine sache wollte ich ja noch machen wir müssen auch noch wir müssen noch mal neu aktivieren
oder neu aktivieren und zwar will ich ja noch den den rechnernamen übermitteln da habe ich
mir vorher schon rausgesucht wie man das ganze gescheit machen kann nämlich so
so gibt es den aktuellen rechnername falsches projekt hier fort ja usernahme und und pc gedöns
ja usernahme und und pc gedöns weil das übergeben wir dem ganzen noch beim diliten
megadresse klar das kann man auch mal megadresse ist eine coole idee ist eigentlich viel besser
wie kriegt man die wie kriegt man die mac raus wahrscheinlich so wie eben das das geht bestimmt
anders network interfaces get all network interface das ist doch auch viel schöner
network interface ip all die name
wie kriegt man denn jetzt da kriegt man wahrscheinlich so auch so die lp raus
operational status ab das ist schon mal ganz interessant weil dann sieht man nämlich nur
die netzwerkinterfaces wo aus eingestöpelt ist ab ab ok physical address ja nice
ja bei mehreren netzwerkern habe ich mehrere megadressen das stimmt aber ab dürften doch
eigentlich nur eine sein zu dem zeitpunkt ich meine das ist frisch installiert auf dem
neuen rechner und ab ist nur die wo kabel drin steckt es kann eigentlich erst mal nur
eine sein ansonsten wenn wir mehrere zur auswahl haben dann kurz gucken was welche adapter
ist das sind die vmw adapters gigabit ab 10 gigabit ab daun daun nee 10 gigabit ist daun
ja gut so wollte ich gerade sagen steht nämlich gar nichts drinne passt eigentlich ganz gut
daun 10 gigabit ist daun normale internetzwerkarte ist ab und die beiden vmw adapter loopback
loopback muss ich noch rausfiltern loopback braucht kein mensch ja hier kann man loopback
machte nämlich hier auch an der stelle und hier sollte loopback dann reinschreiben genau
aber loopback wollen wir nicht ok da können wir uns wirklich ein ordentliches link draus
basteln also kann man sagen netzwerk interface ist where interface status gleich ab mach
das link ganz praktisch und und interface type ungleich loopback ungleich loopback
ja das war es und davon nehmen wir einfach die erste fertig wir machen das ganz einfach
interface nicht interfacer interface interface ach nee interface ist belegt das darf man
nicht übrigens ihr könnt ein add davor machen dann darf man das in c-sharp auch keywörter
als variablenamen verwenden aber das will man eigentlich nicht if geht natürlich e-face
ist noch frei ok das ist meine mac kann man die ordentlich kann man die irgendwie schöner
formatieren kommen mal gucken ob das stimmt sieht man das wie sieht man das überhaupt
richtig jetzt ich weiß gar nicht mal wo man das überhaupt richtig sieht ja doch passt
microsoft sind auch die einzigen die es entweder ohne doppelpunkt oder mit bindestrichen schreiben
ich kenne keines mit bindestrichen oder ich kenne ich kenne es eigentlich nur mit doppelpunkt
ja es sei denn plau ich dachte man hat 10g netzwerkarte on board das war der grund warum
ich das bord damals genommen habe so und jetzt sagen wir noch select
get physical address und jetzt aber fast dann steht der ganze knempel hier drin kann man
das irgendwie noch schöner formatieren die meck warum kauft man sich so ne achso ne du
meinst nicht meins doch meins meins ja doch plau it ab warum nicht fast get physical
address ist eigentlich viel besser hast du recht eigentlich schöner
linkwurm also ich habe von s rock ich habe von s rock einen z3 170 mit 10g ich weiß
aber aus dem kopf nicht mehr wie das heißt aber ich habe ein video gemacht wo das drin
sehen kann ich muss mir gleich noch was zu trinken holen oops fack ich bin mit dem stuhl
übers headset gefahren ripp headset ripp ripp eure oren so ich bin wieder da ja nice
ja dann schreiben wir das interface noch mit rein wir nehmen das erste interface wo der
modus ab ist der netzwerktyp nicht loopback ist so kriege ich doch bestimmt auch meine
ip ordentlich raus oder wie kriege ich denn hier meine wie kann ich denn get address bytes
nehmen moment address ip was ipv4 statistics ip properties da ist doch bestimmt die adresse
irgendwie dabei oder ist das kompliziert nicht einfach unicast addresses das klingt
fast gucken was da jetzt rauskommt adress ja das meine ip session ok so könnte ich
auch meine ip rauskriegen so da merken wir uns die mac wie könnte man das jetzt gescheit
machen wir könnten es kann man das vielleicht informat angeben oder so aber wir können
jetzt irgendwie sagen split oder wie könnte man das jetzt gescheit machen aber schon was
überlegen ich meine wir wollen alle zwei bytes ich hole mal kurz was zu trinken gleich
wieder da wenn ihr eine gute idee habt wie man das richtig richtig schön elegant machen
könnte quasi nach jedem zweiten character einen doppelpunkt einfügen dann seid mal
kreativ ich bin gleich wieder da schon was zu trinken
ich bin gleich wieder da schon was zu trinken
so wieder da ihr macht das alle mit schleifen irgendwie das muss doch schöner gehen oder
man kann to string irgendwelche parameter geben ne das ist ja kein datum oder so oh doch
kann das tatsächlich habe ich gar nicht gesehen ach nee das ist nur für
das ist irgendwie nur wenn ich irgendwelche länder länder spezifischen dinger machen
das lasst mal überlegen wie könnte man das machen
also man könnte man könnte irgendwie man könnte irgendwie irgendwie take range was
gibt's denn für möglichkeiten ich werde es erstmal ohne doppelpunkte lassen bis
mir was gutes eingefallen ist aber da muss es da muss es was schönes kurz das knackiges
dafür geben das ist so ein schönes problem woran man
sich ewig auslassen kann dass man da was schönes gefunden hat
also
kann man gibt es kein split kein split jedes zweite zeichen
ah mit ach man kann sich die bites davon holen ach so
aber das macht nach jedem ja das ist eigentlich eine coole idee
sagt der golfer flow ja also von der idee ist das finde ich finde ich das cool
man das ist das ist beinahe das ist halt formatieren als hex
also ob das prinzipiell tut ja 70 ok passt haben wir den join ich hinten dran
machen ach nee das ist ein sql join vergesst man kann sagen zu array join
da muss man so wirklich so machen dann muss man es wohl wirklich so machen
wobei das nicht auch jetzt nicht das allerschönste ist irgendwie
was vergessen so viele klammern da blinke ich dann mal durch
bis zum ich muss ein paar klammern weg machen noch eine klammer hin
zwingen join ach man separator muss noch angeben klar doppelpunkt objekte ich kann
immer schreiben das ist sehr sehr nice meck sehr sehr nice gefällt mir
das finde ich ich bin ich echt ganz schick so sagen wir die meck von der
kiste so und jetzt sagen wir ihm also wir machen jetzt mal ein neues neues fake
fake activation weil ich ja wieder auf meinem rechner bin hier das telekom ja
sie baro nice dass du da bist geht geht alles so und jetzt brauchen wir
http util util wie schreibt man das utility ist das glaube ich ja und jetzt
müssen wir encode wohl encode machen weil wir wollen das anhängen hinten
dran und encode weil im endeffekt senden wir den delete eigentlich wäre es
besser wenn man den post senden fällt mir gerade auf wir machen nicht die
lead keys wir senden den post na doch wir belassen es mal bei die lit
kann man kann man im delete kann man da im body was mit schicken geht das
probieren wir mal habe ich noch nie getestet
nie getestet ob man den delete im body was mit schicken kann
ja aber dass man was reinschreiben kann ist klar ich habe keine ahnung ob der
das auswertet stimmt ich habe gestern eine leger collection gesendet stimmt ja
mal gucken mal gucken ob das funktioniert jetzt
progas starten
warum ist eigentlich das programm gesperrt richtig bescheuert wenn ich
das andere starte
dann machen wir es nämlich nicht mit all encode dann packen wir das hinten
rein
wie macht man in eine name value collection was rein war das das wieder
kompliziert microsoft please bla bla was weiß ich wie das heißt so kann man
da jetzt alles rein stecken add ok swing test value merkt blub so mal gucken
ob das im delete jetzt ankommt
was mache ich da blub nicht add so mal gucken ob das im delete jetzt ankommt
jetzt bin ich brauchst noch kies zum testen sebaro wenn du den key hast einen
off stream oder so falls du welche hast könnten wir schon machen und zu
verifizieren dass es das ist aktivieren wirklich funktioniert aber brauche ich
unbedingt es können die jungs auch morgen selbst testen ich meine wir
müssen hier keine windows keys zum fenster rausschmeißen au moment das
führen wir jetzt hier garantiert nicht aus
das führen wir jetzt gerne hier auf meinem rechner nicht aus weil es eh
kein admin ok ist window aktiviert blabla gucken wir mal ups hat das jetzt
funktioniert hat das jetzt funktioniert
da müsste stehen nicht funktioniert ok upload string einfach mal so merke
wobei das wird auch nicht funktionieren
ich habe sie dazu gemacht ich kann das web interface noch ein
bisschen aufrüsten das kann ja noch gar nichts wollte dann noch logs rein
machen und alles da müssen wir tatsächlich mal wieder stack
overflow zu befragen
wobei es könnte auch sein dass ich sagen muss
from body kann auch sein vielleicht so vielleicht so
ich brauche den windows key
1 2 3 4 5 zack brauche testdings gedöns
ok habe ich denn auch test genannt
ja echt über jetzt ob es jetzt funktioniert
wau nee kriegt er nicht gebacken
der kriegt das nicht gebacken
den delete mit sachen drin ok wir fragen was deck overflow
ok man darf es anscheinend nicht
alles ja blöd
ja dann müssen wir es doch in die url packen
ja die pasen sich das irgendwo raus
ist ja dann weil ich ja dann müssen wir dann hängen wir es doch in die url an so wie ich
mir das am anfang gedacht habe also body in geht nicht na gut
wenn das nicht funktioniert dann sagen wir form form query das ist dann quasi
name von dem meck die meck adresse von dem rechner die meck adresse von dem
rechner die aktiviert wurde schauen wir mal ob das funktioniert jetzt meck
just for meck
ob es jetzt funktioniert also schmeißen wir den knempel weg
war wieder leer so und dann url encode wir das ganze meck und hängen das in
die url hinten an das macht jetzt zwar auch nicht gerade schöner dass man da
quasi noch hinschreiben müssen gleich meck gleich meck was sieht es eklig aus
jetzt ha ha ha wie schön ist was anderes want to activate yes aktivating
ha ha guck mal wir haben eine meck das funktioniert max verwende string interpolation ja das machen
wir auch gleich das schon richtig so und wenn wir jetzt in die datenbank
reingucken sollte da auch drinne stehen just for meck adresse
oh das ist cool na das ist nice dass es funktioniert ich würde sagen das richt schroggers
morgen hart verrat also ich denke morgen könnt ihr es ausprobieren wir bauen jetzt
noch ein bisschen schnick schnack ein wenn das prinzipiell tut bei euch da mach
ich die keyverwaltung noch ein bisschen schöner weil aktuell ist es einfach
ein textfeld der was sich ein bisschen nervig bedienen lässt aber wenn es
prinzipiell funktioniert machen wir das noch den wünschen deines untertarns
entsprechend dass man ein kommentar hinzufügen kann welche key lieferung das
ist gibt es auf github ja ich lade es auf github noch so jetzt war mal die lock
seite weil das war auf jeden fall wir haben jetzt so viele keys und so schon
drinne wir wollen jetzt noch auswerten welche keys wurden gejusst
so deswegen ich will dafür nichts ich will dafür streben wir hätten einfach
einen 20 zeilen power shells machen können und das hier ist die schönere
variante und außerdem habe ich das ja auch vorgeschlagen dass ich das macht
dass ich halt hier im stream zeigen kann dass ich was kurzes übersichtliches
hab wo man halt weißt du nix wo irgendwie wieder monate dauert sondern
was wo ich einfach mal in 1 2 3 tagen fertig machen kann
ein deal mit der video hast du mit envider irgendwas laufen
ich habe mit denen früher auch ein paar sachen gemacht
falls ja würde mich interessieren kannst du privat schreiben wer dort dein
kontakt ist
so
genau wir wollten jetzt noch die locks einbauen weil das ist eigentlich so
das feature was es auch ein bisschen abhebt vom rest
ach so ne ne ach nee ich dachte jetzt für youtube du hast irgendwie mit
in dem community manager oder mit sonst was kontakt weil ich wollte einfach mal
wissen ob noch die gleichen leute da sind die ich auch noch kennen
ok wir machen jetzt neuen controller so und das geht jetzt schnell aber das
wirkt ganz nice
neue controller das ist der lock controller so der lock controller der
hat controller base kann immer noch nicht richtig tippen
controller base konstruktor kriegen wir ab db kontext kontext haupts habe ich
jetzt gemacht
ich will usen
so da brauchen wir jetzt eigentlich nur genau eine methode und zwar die main
geschichte das werden hatte tippe get public ein amore be widows leisens widows
leisens get logs
ups
kontext leisens und jetzt kommt der gag daran leisens nur die leisens die
benutzt werden wo man die logs schreiben so dann brauchen wir jetzt noch hier
einmal kopieren wir nehmen logs
aktiv
so da haben wir jetzt eine schöne tabelle rein
also die get key methode müssen ein bisschen ändern und zwar wir wollen nicht
api key wir wollen api logs holen jason response key bin ich in der richtigen datei
die ganzen anderen krempel können wir rausschmeißen so jetzt haben wir uns die
keys gegettet
auch mal starten
ich habe eine sache vergessen wartet kurz
ich habe vergessen beim controller dabei zu schreiben unter welcher adresse er
verfügbar sein soll
logs alles wird jetzt ganz nice gleich logs so ok die form brauchen wir nicht
mehr
da war jetzt die tabelle table also table was brauche man da key datum oder
sowas wie nennt man das
wie just wir können uns da was schönes ausdenken und irgendwie meck so und jetzt
brauchen wir einfach in der vorschleife
wie vor
key in keys und dann sagen wir table
und da soll jetzt reinkommen warum schreibe ich eigentlich immer keys keys
ist doof das ding heißt ja nicht das sind eigentlich viel mehr als keys
wir nennt es eigentlich sind ja lizenzen da steht ja noch viel mehr dabei also
eigentlich wollen wir sowas wie leisens in auch schöner leisens leisens
hier sehr schön leisens key dann wollen wir haben just and und wir wollen haben
die just vor so das wird ja beide noch ein bisschen ein bisschen ordentlich
formatieren weil so sieht es scheiße aus aber das ist doch nice da kann man
nachgucken ich copy paste mir jetzt einfach was
styles ich copy paste mir hier mal was aus der anderen seite wo habe ich es
denn ja aber wie passte
ah es sieht doch schon mal viel besser aus oder
es sieht ja schon mal ganz nice aus jetzt siehst du hier quasi welcher
windows key wann eingelöst wurde und von welcher meck jetzt brauchen wir bloß
noch was was das datum ordentlich formatiert irgendwie sowas datetime
so und jetzt kommt ein bisschen javascript magic also format datetime
da schieben wir den dotnet datetime rein unter dotnet datetime sind gepasst in
javascript millisekunden seit 1970 weil warum es ausgerechnet millisekunden seit
1970 sind keine ahnung weil irgendjemand spaß daran hat komische formate sich
auszudenken
jetzt haben wir hier das datum drin und jetzt können wir das datum formatieren
und zwar kann man sagen return date to local date string da kann man sagen wir
wollen es auf jeden fall in deutschem format haben
konkret sieht das ganze auch viel schöner aus von ich habe es falsche
genommen ich habe die meck adresse versucht als als datetime zu passen
na gut kann ja mal passieren ja so ist doch schon besser oder
ja ich weiß dass es unix time ist aber warum möchte man bitteschön den javascript
datetime standardmäßig als millisekunden seit 1970 haben sie
genau nehmen oder so ist auch cool oder hier hat man die keys hier passen wir
passen jetzt würde ich sagen hier auch noch mal text box text area text text
area wir haben dafür noch gar nichts angelegt ok
dann kopiere ich mir das nämlich von auch einfach von hier einfach ein nice copy paste
das ist auch schick was gefällt mir
hier hast du deine keys drinne hier hast du logs drinne so ist das stream abgekackt
mit der musik das ist auch schick was dazu geben oder so ganz nice so und
hier hast du dann die übersicht man muss die übersicht natürlich auch ein bisschen
beschneiden zum beispiel dass man sagt ja das hardware art das hat der gabi
rally schon erzählt das baue ich ein nachdem ihr es ausprobiert habt weil
aktuell ist es relativ billig es ist einfach ein textfeld wo keys reinkommen
da müssen wir das nämlich ein bisschen aufsplitten dann machen wir hier kein
textfeld wo die keys reinkommen dann machen wir hier einen hinzufügen knopf
dann geht das textfeld auf kannst du die keys reinpaste oben noch ein kommentar
drüber das geht jetzt so grad nicht das das mache ich dann nachdem es
ausprobiert habt
nachdem es ausprobiert haben aber das dann auch mit dem mit ihr könnt ja
morgen einfach mal mit zwei keys oder so ausprobieren ob sich das aktivieren
prinzipiell funktioniert
aber jetzt noch mal ins discord oder so noch dabei und du guckst einfach mal
ob es geht weil wie gesagt ich konnte alles testen hier als außerhalb eben das
aktivieren selbst
und wenn das alles geht und alles drinne ist was du brauchst dann gucken wir
ob was irgendwie als docker container für der nass basteln
wie hast du denn das aktivieren implementiert das ist das ist eine
konsolenanwendung die kommt halt auf den server auf den auf den kleinen drauf
und die schickt einfach die holt sich den die holt sich den key vom server und
nachdem das aktivieren erfolgreich war hier guck da wenn es aktivieren
erfolgreich war dann sagt sie dem server hier markiere mal diesen key als
benutzt und dann nimmt der server den raus
ich bin es gerade eine idee gekommen wie man das noch viel besser machen kann
wir benutzen einfach bei keycontroller wir benutzen kein delete wir benutzen
kein delete sondern wir benutzen ein putt weil putt ist eigentlich das rest
wort das schlüssel wort für item ändern
wat der verschmerzen ist eigentlich viel besser weil jetzt können wir die meck
auch so als als string übergeben glaube ich hoffe ich die log seit noch mit einer
seitenfunktion ausstatten ja das waren wir das ist alles noch so fein tuning ich
will jetzt so die basis funktion alle rein kriegen ich hätte zum beispiel gerne
noch mal so ein beispielgraf auf der auf der statistik seite so was wie heute
aktiviert pro stunde oder so was machen wir da einfach rein
bitte noch hardcoded server ip denken mache ich alles noch mache ich noch wie
gesagt ich schicke euch das ja eh erst morgen wenn ich wach bin dann und da
können wir mal gucken
oh jetzt haben wir hier die merke so ein bisschen putt machen ist glaube ich
besser
putt
was haben wir hier eigentlich alles zur ausfahrt upload upload values upload data
upload file upload string
die upload values klingt irgendwie am 17 nächsten
upload values
okay muss jetzt doch den klein opp
merk
so jetzt funktioniert's hoffentlich
Keycontroller
Jetzt ist ein Putt, bin ich mal gespannt ob das jetzt klappt
Bei Context denkst du eher bei CTX denkst an Citrix
Ich hab mir das angewöhnt, ich schreib das überall, Context mit CTX
Aber das ist schon, kann ich verstehen, das ist Geschmackssache
Okay, Ausführen, Activate, blablabla, wartet mal kurz
So, mal gucken ob das jetzt funktioniert hat
Immer noch nicht, warum?
Alter, wo hat er denn jetzt damit Probleme, bitte schön
Warum geht denn der Kram jetzt hier an der Stelle nicht
Das kann man so vielleicht mal ausprobieren
Ich hab Systemintegration gelernt vor über 10 Jahren
Hat er jetzt überhaupt was gemacht
Okay, was genau hat er denn jetzt für Schmerzen
Oh, from body, wie macht man das denn jetzt richtig
Putt, wie schicke ich das denn jetzt, Upload, Webclient
Update, Produkt, Async, okay
Putt ist Jason Async
Okay, wir machen jetzt mal was anderes
Wir rufen das jetzt von, wir rufen das jetzt mal mit irgendeinem ordentlichen Tool auf, wo man gucken kann was passiert
Wir speichern das ganze auch nicht
Kann das sein, dass, wartet mal, kann das sein, dass das hier zuerst kommen muss
So was hier
So und jetzt gucken wir uns das mal an, habe ich hier Postman drauf, Postman, nein, dann installieren wir das jetzt mal
Bestes Tool für irgendwelche Rest-APs zum ausprobieren was da so passiert
Da können wir das nämlich mal ordentlich debunken, dann weiß ich auch was ich mit meinem Client dahinschicken muss
Moin, Official Limitix
Weißt du, wisst ihr was richtig, richtig cool finde auf Twitch
Das wichtigste ist, und wie gesagt, ich habe im Vergleich zu wirklich großnetz nicht viele Zuschauer
Aber was ich gemerkt habe, was das wichtigste auf Twitch ist, was man Zuschauer bekommt und Zuschauer hält
Es ist natürlich schon von Vorteil, wenn man auf YouTube schon eine gewisse Größe hat, keine Frage, das wichtigste ist
Und das kannst du echt universal auf Twitch sagen ist, regelmäßig streamen
Regelmäßig streamen, das ist einfach so krass wie ich bin, der Unterschied zwischen ich habe ein paar Wochen nicht gestreamt und streamen wieder
Zu ich stream alle paar Tage, ich stream, ich, keine Ahnung, ich habe 4-5 Wochen nicht gestreamt, ich habe 80 Zuschauer
Ich stream ein paar Tage am Stück, die Leute kriegen es wieder mit, ich habe 160
Wir haben heute peak 200, das ist bei einem sinnlosen Programmier-Stream
Ok, put, put, meine Adresse ist, ja, http da oder was ist das
164 slash api slash tees slash 1
Oder, weißte nicht, sql browser, was ist denn die verfügbare
Oh wir haben schon ein paar IDs eingefügt
ID 9690
Could not get response, warum
Kommt nix an, warum
Wo ist das Problem
Ah, ich hab mich verschrieben
Aha, wat
War doch meine api oder
Ah, port, ich kann ja mal denken, jetzt
So, und da kann man jetzt reinschreiben, body
Soll ich jason oder so machen, jason, text
So
So fast, ich weiß nicht, was du da für Dinge postest, aber das hat nix hier mit dem stream zu tun
Ich weiß nicht, was es ist, aber ich hab hier so ein browserplugin, was mir ne vorschau anzeigt, sind irgendwelche
So, und da kann man ja mal denken, was du da für Dinge postest, aber das hat nix hier mit dem stream zu tun
So, kurz meine vorschau reloaden
So, jetzt gucken wir mal, dass wir den parameters, probieren wir es mal da drüber, das müsste ja direkt funktionieren
Also wollen wir sagen, hier mac ist blub blub blub, send, mac ist blub blub blub, funktioniert
Und das ist, wenn es in der url drinnen ist
Body, parameter
Text, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das richtig schreibt, blub blub blub, send
Okay, funktioniert so nicht
Wie sieht das eigentlich richtig aus, ich hab gar keine Ahnung, wie schreibt man das richtig in body rein
Ah, so
Usually content type ist blablabla, url encoded, okay
Und dann sagt man mac, gleich blub blub blub, funktioniert aber nicht
Funktioniert nicht, weil da nicht from body dransteht, machen wir das mal
From body, wollen wir mal rauskriegen, wie der campaign funktioniert
Also übrigens, wenn ihr mal rest apes und gedöns debagen müsst, kann ich euch nur diesen team, den postman, echt nur empfehlen, das ist echt praktisch
Kann man sich alles angucken
Hallo, hat das jetzt, input was not valid, warum
Warum ist mein input not valid
Das war ursprünglich eine browser erweiterung, hier, was ist die, bloß dass chrome ja sagt sie unterstützen keine addon ap mehr
Aller wo ist denn jetzt mein problem, wo ist dann das problem dabei
Kann ich hier irgendwie sagen content type oder so
Oh man, wo ist denn das problem jetzt hier, das war ich dann falsch
From body, okay, good, nice
Oh man, ich kann immer nachdenken, fall ab geht das nicht
Also, weg, send, macht er nicht, nichts drin
Auch nichts drin, ich bin gerade echt überfragt, wie ich den
Ja, noch nicht zu kompliziert sein, nicht, weil mit dem post funktioniert es doch auch
Ich check echt nicht, wo das Problem ist
Er sagt ja auch, we will encode it
Moment, ich hab ne Idee, wir brauchen nicht, haha, wartet mal, wir brauchen nicht from body, wir brauchen
Wir brauchen nicht from body, wir brauchen from form wahrscheinlich einfach nur
Ha, haha, warum immer, from form geht, from form ist okay, from form funktioniert
Nice
Okay, dann wissen wir jetzt, was wir machen müssen
So, dann gucken wir erstmal, ob der upload funktioniert
Mit dem Kogas tool
Ja, funktioniert
Okay, aus irgendwelchen Gründen müssen wir from form nehmen anstatt from body
Ich hab keine Ahnung warum, ist mir aber auch scheißegal, funktioniert
Vollkommen egal
Okay, das tut
Ha, da sind die ganzen weep emotes am start im chat
Okay, gut, funktioniert
So, was machen wir denn als nächstes, was haben wir denn hier schönes, noch offen
Dass wir hier noch Kommentare dazu schreiben können, habe ich mir aufgeschrieben, zwar nachdem der Test erfolgreich war
Wollen wir noch, wollen wir jetzt mal richtig, richtig advanced sein und unter stats
Wollen wir unter stats noch einen graph einbinden, der anzeigt wieviel keys pro stunde aktiviert wurden
Komm, das waren wir noch, oder, da haben wir noch ein bisschen eye candy dabei
Kann man einbauen, dass sich die Kleinex in einer erfolgreichen Aktivierung selbst löscht
Ja, ich schreibe es mir mal auf, wobei ich mir eher gedacht habe
Wobei ich mir eher gedacht habe, die Kleinex sollte sich nicht selbst löschen, sondern die sollte einen custom script von euch ausführen
Indem ihr dann unter anderem die Exe löschen könnt, weil dann könntet ihr danach noch x beliebige Sachen ausführen lassen
Im Prinzip könntet ihr alles ausführen lassen, was ihr halt in ein powershell script reinschreiben könnt
Warum also irgendwas essenzielles, was ich noch vergessen habe
Nach der Aktivierung ist der PC fertig
Ja, vielleicht wollt ihr ja Sachen machen, also habt ihr halt auch gestern gemeint, irgendwie sowas wie ihr wollt einen script haben
Was euch quasi unverwendete Festplatten formatiert und sowas
Das müsst ihr natürlich selber machen, aber das könnte man ausführen lassen automatisch, da muss man das nicht jedes mal von Hand machen
Also auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt, wenn das Ding einen custom script ausführen kann
Ne, die Exe ist nicht auf dem USB Stick, die Exe ist im Installer drin
Ne, das ist nicht das aktuelle Projekt, das ist nur eingeschoben, wie das Ebaro schreibt
So, das heißt, wir machen jetzt noch einen
Kopieren wir den Kram mal
Aus dem Key Controller wird ein Stat Controller für Statistik
Das Copy Paste ich mir aber aus anderen Sachen, die ich schon hab zusammen jetzt
Stat Controller
Und der braucht im Endeffekt nur ein Get
Nur ein Get, allerdings mit Custom All
Ein Get auf Today
Da gibt es dann quasi jetzt schön kopiert die Sachen, die heutzutage, die heute eingelöst wurden
So, und wie kriegen wir die Sachen raus, die heute eingelöst wurden
Und zwar, würde ich sagen, erst mal brauchen wir Today
Today ist Date Time, jetzt kommt Reg 17
Ist auch eine coole Sache
Also, könnte nützlich sein für Leute, die sich abhauen können
Date Time Now kennt wahrscheinlich jeder
Aber wenn man sagt DateTimeNow.date, also von dem aktuellen DateTime Objekt
Mit Date kriegt man quasi nur die Datumsportion raus und alles andere ist auf Null gesetzt
Das heißt, ich bekomme jetzt den DateTime raus heute um Null Uhr
Was ich gut vergleichen kann mit den Zeitstempeln hier drinnen
Weil jetzt will ich quasi alle License Keys haben
Die used sind
Und
Used ad größer ist
Als Today
Das heißt im Prinzip alle
Bei so einer einfachen Abfrage geht das
Also im Prinzip alles, was heute aktiviert wurde
So, und jetzt müssen wir das noch groupen
Group by
Ah, ist das Team abgeschissen
Nutzt du auf deinem Server Linux oder bin du aus Linux?
Auf dem Server würde ich nie mehr das erzählen
Group by DateTime
Used ad
Halt, für Schmerzen
Ach so, ja, das ist klar, das nicht funktioniert
Group by Used ad Stunde
Ja
Und jetzt, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt bekommen wir da sowas hier raus im Endeffekt
Jetzt kriegen wir quasi ein Objekt raus, was hier drinnen stehen hat
Stunde, keine Ahnung, Stunde, aktuelle Stunde ist 18
Und in 18 wurden so und so viele Keys aktiviert
Blablabla
In 19 so und so viele Keys und sowas
Haben wir da jetzt drinnen stehen
Select
Da machen wir mal einen Zeitumbruch hin
Ich kann mich immer nicht entscheiden, ob Punkt vor oder Punkt nach, ja
Select Group
Key
Ach so, wir müssen uns jetzt an irgendwas überlegen, was wir da returnen können
Key Value Pair ist wahrscheinlich das einfachste
Key Value Pair aus Stunde und Anzahl
Ja
New Key Value Pair
Stunde
Und Anzahl
Müsste das jetzt, müsste so passen, hoffe ich
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt quasi hier anfrage, AP Stats
Probieren wir das doch mal mit Postman gleich aus
Kommen wir mal gleich mal was wir da zurück kriegen
Postman
Ja, und zwar diesmal wollen wir haben AP Keys
AP Stats Today
Und iPhone und ein Get
Ja, ist doch nice, guck mal
Um 15 Uhr, also in
In der Stunde 15 Uhr
Haben wir zwei Keys aktiviert, 16 oder 6 Keys
17 oder 4 Keys
Can you help me with Fourier Analysis? No
I can't
So, jetzt kriegen wir dann ein ordentliches Array zurück
Obwohl es kein Array ist, aber es gibt Objekte drin
Und da könnte man jetzt einfach einen Graph draus bauen
Ich würde sagen, wir machen so einen
So einen Balkendiagramm oder so
Oder was meint ihr, wir gucken mal, also wir werden das hier vernennen
Das, es gibt
Gott und die Welt hunderttausende JavaScript
Graph Bibliotheken, die einzige mit der ich bisher was gemacht habe ist die hier
Und die ist auch echt ganz nice, die gibt es auch noch für Python und ich glaube
Java
Ich weiß gar nicht, für was es die alles gibt
Products
Ach, keine Ahnung
Zumindest
Was nehmen wir dafür? Ich würde ja sagen, so einen
So einen Balken, so einen Balkendiagramm ist eigentlich am schönsten
Einfach so einen Balkendiagramm, so nach dem Motto
Ey
Keine Ahnung, 15 Uhr, 16 Uhr, 17 Uhr
Oder so was in der Richtung, würde ich sagen
Weil die alle anderen Diagramm Typen sehen viel zu abgedreht aus
Weil ich meine, ich brauch keinen 2D Density Plot
Wenn ich einfach anzeigen lassen würde, wieviel Keys in der Stolle eingelöst wurden
Okay, um
Stats
Also passen wir das hier mal an, gleich Stats habe ich schon gemacht
Ob die Seite jetzt am Start ist oder nicht
Stats
Ja, funktioniert, okay
Active
Okay
Okay, das Ding kommt weg
Da bleibt jetzt nur noch ein Diff übrig
Das Diff kriegt die I.D. Chart
Das werden wir uns zusammen Copy Pasten, klar
Was hast du für ein Lied? Oh, Ubuntu
Ubuntu, beste
Ich bin Fan von Ubuntu Server
Weiß gar nicht, warum das immer so schlecht geredet wird
Ich finde viel angenehmer zu benutzen als, sagen wir mal, Red Hat oder sowas
Auf dem Desktop mag ich dafür kein Ubuntu
Ich finde es ja witzig, ne
Die meisten Leute verbinden mit Ubuntu ein Desktop Betriebssystem
Ich verwende das auf dem Desktop überhaupt nicht
Da verwende ich nur Majaro
Das ist so ein Arch Linux Abkömmling
Und auf dem Server verwende ich da Ubuntu, wo quasi alle anderen irgendwie
Red Hat oder Susie oder, was sind denn noch schöne Zeug, der Debian verwenden
Nämlich Ubuntu
Red Hat läuft auf Ubuntu, ja die Jungs wissen ja auch, was sie machen
Reddit Server ist wunderbar, äh, nicht Reddit Server, Ubuntu Server ist ganz toll
Aktuellere Pakete spricht dafür bei Ubuntu
Ein paar Entscheidungen von Ubuntu sind fragwürdig, ja
Wie diese komische Jaml-Netzwerk-Config, die braucht kein Mensch
Aber alles in allem ist Ubuntu die Server-Distribution, die mich am wenigsten nervt
Ansonsten für alle Debian-Fans ist halt auch nicht viel Unterschied
So in Basic-Sachen anzwischen
So, ähm, Chart
Okay, ähm
Also, wie machen wir das denn jetzt mit der Grafik
Als erstes müssen wir erstmal Plotly einbinden
So, Plotly
Den Krempel machen wir wieder weg, den brauchen wir hier nicht
So, eigentlich brauchen wir hier gar nichts Großartiges, wir brauchen ja auch den Kram nicht
Können wir mal wegmachen komplett, wir müssen eigentlich nur
Und Data, ja, Data brauchen wir sowas wie Licenses Today
Vielleicht lass ich mal das Get-Keys doch da
Get-Keys, Licenses
Genau, also wir Fetchen jetzt Stats
Und da kriegen wir den Jason zurück mit unserem Geschwubbel drin
Und da speichern wir ja Licenses Today
Speichern wir das drinnen
So, kann man eigentlich Mounted Async machen
Schauen wir mal aus, Await
So, und jetzt muss wir da unser Plotly, aber das Copy-Paste ich mir von was anderem, was ich hier habe, rein
Also, ohbei, das ist eigentlich ziemlich übersichtlich
Also wir brauchen ein Data-Feld
Mit ähm
Folgenden Sachen drinnen
Y-Graph ist keine Ahnung, erstmal Null
X-Graph ist auch erstmal Null
Dann Array aus Null
So, und dann muss man auch sagen Type und dann hier Balkendiagramm
Und jetzt kommt Plotly, New Plot, Chart, Data
Das war's, mehr brauchen wir eigentlich für so einen Billig-Graph erstmal gar nicht
Da wird natürlich jetzt nichts drinnen sein, aber es wird einen Graph anzeigen, hoffe ich
Nein, warum nicht
Aber
Habe ich irgendwas vergessen
Sündtagsfehler
Ah, hier, ne
Wo habe ich einen Sündtagsfehler produziert, Leute
Falsche Url
Url ist richtig
Wenn man so lange davor sitzt, da sieht man es nicht
Ah, jetzt haben wir auch, jetzt haben wir schon krassen Graph am Start
Der zwar noch nichts macht, der aber ergraft schonmal rum
So, der kriegt jetzt noch ein paar Optionen mit
Und zwar, Title, nennen wir sowas wie aktivierte Rechner
Heute, irgendwie so
Das Programm ist echt eine wilde Mischung aus Deutsch und Englisch
Jetzt haben wir Höhe, 250
Ganz so hoch muss das Ding ja nicht sein
Ups
Ja, nice
So, und jetzt müssen wir noch sagen
Eigentlich müssten wir gar nichts mehr machen, oder
Das sieht doch ganz okay aus
Dann füllen wir jetzt einfach mal unsere Daten rein und mal gucken wie das Ganze aussieht
Ach ja doch, ich sehe hier
Bei meinem anderen Projekt noch eine Sache, die kann ich mir jetzt copypasten
Was ich immer noch machen muss, dass es besser aussieht, ist das hier
Da kommt nämlich kein komisches Overlay hier
So, jetzt haben wir unsere Keys
Und jetzt können wir uns quasi rausholen, also für die Y-Achse
Und da wollen wir jetzt einfach nur rausholen
Den Wert, wie viele Lizenzen aktiviert wurden
Aha, ich meine die X-Achse stimmt noch nicht, aber prinzipiell ist es schon mal ganz gut
Und X
Da brauchen wir jetzt ein bisschen mehr
So, und da wollen wir sagen, License
Und da brauchen wir jetzt ein Datum
Also das aktuelle
Und wir resetten alles
Was kann man da machen
Bis auf die Stunde
Und die Stunde ist Key, das wissen wir ja
Das haben wir hier reingeschrieben, in Key die die Stunde, wann das Ganze angelegt wurde
So, Minute 0, Dings 0, alles 0
Zack
Return Date
Nice, guck mal, und zack haben wir einen Graph
Wie was aktiviert wurde, das ist doch mega poggers, oder
Jetzt haben wir hier nochmal Width
Irgendwie 600
Das ist doch cool, doch sehr, sehr nice
Warum finde ich nicht, ich finde das zart was
Das staucht aus
Ah, ich hab noch was vergessen, das Copy Paste, ich mach nochmal
Ich hab hier noch was, gucken ob das was bringt
Das ändert nichts, oder
Ist es nicht ein wenig overkillt für so eine simple Seite View anzuziehen, doch
Aber wir haben genug Rechenleistung
Ich finde das eigentlich ganz hübsch so
Jetzt haben wir die Keyverwahl, jetzt haben wir ein paar Locks
Und wir haben noch wie viele Sachen die Stunde aktiviert wurden
Das ist doch cool
Kann man vielleicht ein bisschen kleiner machen, dass keine Zwischentritte mehr angezeigt werden
Ja, so ist nice, oder
Was würde passieren wenn man jetzt Javascript im Browser macht
Du siehst kein Inhalt mehr
Du siehst kein Inhalt mehr, du siehst ein leeres Textfeld
Du siehst eine leere Tabelle und du siehst eine leere Seite
Das würde passieren wenn du Javascript ausmachst
Aber das ist doch schicker
Ich meine das ist ein bisschen overkill, das braucht wahrscheinlich kein Mensch
Aber ich finde es ist irgendwie nice
Ja
Irgendwie gefällt mir das
Wo man noch ein bisschen gucken muss, das hier sieht nicht so ganz konsistent zu dem da aus
Kann es sein, dass die Hintergrundfarbe hier komplett anders ist als bei dem
Das müssen wir noch ändern
Text area read only
Oder haben wir disabled gesetzt und nicht read only
Muss ich mal kurz schauen
Ah disabled haben wir gesetzt
Disabled brauchen wir eigentlich
Das sieht schon viel besser aus
Borderradius 50%
50% nicht so
Ja das ist doch beste
Jetzt sieht man besonders viel noch
Aber wir können ja die Textboxen ein bisschen abgerundet machen
Wie kann man eigentlich das resize ausschalten
Okay das geht anscheinend nur mit CSS
Das ist doch hübsch
Das gefällt mir sehr gut
Das geht mit der Musik ab
Moin Juli Genetikus
Ich finde das sehr nice
Irgendwie hat das was oder
Ich meine hier kann man noch mehr Statistiken rein machen, aber das ist ja nur wirklich Spielerei gerade
Da könnt ihr sehen wo ihr die meisten Rechner aktiviert habt
Aber morgen wird erst mal getestet ob das prinzipiell funktioniert
Alles zentriert
Jetzt kann ich euch einbauen
Kann ich euch einbauen? Das ist kein großer Ack.
Bitte, kein Sound, das ist doch affisch.
Na, man könnte ein Ding-Sound machen, sobald ein Key aktiviert wurde.
Ja, der Browser soll nicht Bing machen, der Server soll Bing machen, das ist klar.
Please sweep, TTS, ne, das baue ich da nicht ein.
Ähm, ich wollte das noch zentrieren, alles, ne?
Kann man eigentlich einfach sagen, geht das? Ich hab mich noch nie ausgebildet.
Kann ich jetzt sagen, Body, Align, ne, wie geht denn das?
Text-Align, Center, geht das? Und ist jetzt alles zentriert? Fast.
Wie kriege ich den Mist auch noch zentriert hier?
Mach, was? March in Auto? Ne, wat, wie, wo?
Ach so, warte mal, ich setze das Zeug ja hier explizit auf Left, ne?
Ja, aber jetzt ist es untereinander, das ist auch dumm.
Oh, ich hab mit CSS echt, bin ich nicht so der geile CSS-Owner?
Ich find's auch so zentriert, ehrlich gesagt, das ist geil, ich war so geil.
Der Edit-Button darf ein bisschen größer sein vor allem.
Nicht minders. Marchen von links ein bisschen, ja.
Bisschen viel, und oben können wir auch ein bisschen Marchen machen, 10 Pixels oder so.
Ja, das ist doch ganz hübsch.
Die Tabelle machen wir auch Border-Radius, 2.
Geht das nicht? Kann man keine abgerundeten Tabellen machen mit CSS?
Kann das sein, dass das nicht funktioniert?
Ach so, vielleicht soll ich noch eine Farbe angeben.
Weißt du, die schwarzen Linien, meinst du, die hier? Wo hab ich sie denn?
Ja, das sieht besser aus.
So, meinst du, so ist besser?
Okay, den Header zentrieren, ja, das ist eigentlich ganz gut.
Allerdings, wir wollen nur den Header zentrieren.
Warum genau hat er das jetzt nicht zentriert?
Ach so, weil ich gar keinen Header verwendet hab.
Wie geht denn das nochmal mit Table-Header-Orca? Das ist immer so das Struggle.
Ja, TH. Ah, wobei, ob das zentriert so viel besser aussieht als...
Na, ich find's schon so schicker.
Macht das was?
Nicht wirklich.
Ja, aber so kann das bleiben. Da müssen wir jetzt noch eine Überschrift hin machen.
BigFont, BigShark.
Da haben wir jetzt noch hier, kommt noch hin, unter das Navigationsding.
A3, please.
Das ist leicht eigentlich.
Ansonsten brauchen wir da gar nichts mehr dazwischen, oder?
So war am besten.
Unbenutzte Keys.
So, dann gibt's jetzt noch hier eine Überschrift auf der anderen Seite.
Nicht unbenutzte Keys.
Statistiken.
So, und Ballocks.
History. Da fällt jetzt grad nichts anderes ein.
So, echt ganz schick geworden.
Jetzt noch Windows 10 VM. Was meinst du, was ich hier hab?
Problem ist, dass ich keinen Key hab zum Aktivieren.
Ja, wir haben's ja schon ausprobiert.
Es geht außer das Aktivieren. Geht alles.
Auch im Fehlerfall macht er den Key nicht weg.
Aber mir gefällt das jetzt echt ganz gut.
Wir machen jetzt noch... Vielleicht sollten wir das hier...
Das binden wir dann alles noch mal über eine gemeinsame Seite drum herum ein.
Also es ist ein bisschen eklig, wenn man das alles immer Copy-Pasten muss.
Achso. Oh, ich noob.
Ich glaube nicht, dass der Button damit gut aussieht.
Der ist dann einfach rund.
Irgendwie finde ich das echt cool. Das gefällt mir.
Die zwei Seiten sehen ja konsistent aus. Die Textbox gefällt mir noch nicht so gut.
Hast mir Windows 10 key geschickt. Ja, das kann ich aber nicht auf Stream machen.
Aber Leute, ich muss jetzt auch gleich mal was vortragen. Ich hab übeles Hunger.
Hier kann man dann später noch andere Statistiken rein machen, die einem was bringen.
Ich finde das echt cool. Mir gefällt das jetzt.
Ich konnte da jetzt eine Weile durchklicken. Irgendwie hat was was.
Was ich mag ist, dass die Webseite super simpel ist.
Das was ich bei den meisten Webseiten vermisse. Du hast zigtausend Dinge, was dir auf den Sack geht.
Und hier ist im Prinzip nichts drin, außer das was du sehen willst.
Du hast ein Textfeld mit Keys, wo du Keys reinpastet kannst.
Und er halt nur die Keys speichert, die nicht doppelt sind.
Du hast History von Keys, die aktiviert wurden. Und wann?
Aber der View-Teil ist nun wirklich simpel überall.
Hätten wir einen ordentlichen Build-Step, so mit Webpack oder so, könnten wir auch ordentlich View-Komponenten verwenden.
Und müssten nicht auf jeder Seite View neu einbinden.
Anti-Ed-Block, das Ding läuft intern, da ist es vollkommen egal.
Mach doch eine Animation für den Tabwechsel rein. Könnte man machen.
Könnte man machen.
Zeig mal, was hat uns denn der Sebaro da für einen Code-Pen geschickt?
Ach die Uhrzeit, WTF, die habe ich ja ganz vergessen.
Ja klar, die Uhrzeit muss da auch noch rein.
Klar muss die da auch noch rein.
Oh, Uhrzeit. Ja, ja, schon mal klein besser.
Was willst du nur mit dem Datum?
So, was hat uns der Sebaro hier geschickt?
Oh, das sieht natürlich richtig brau aus.
Aber schon wieder übel Slam. Guck mal, kommt gar nicht hinterher mit dem Klicken.
Aber die Transition hier unten finde ich ganz cool. Wie macht er denn das?
Das ist J-Hurri, ne?
Wie macht denn hier unten die Transition zwischen den... das Überplanten, wie macht er denn das?
Was? Guckt ihr das mal bitte an. Kann ich das einfach so aufmachen, ohne...
Obwohl, ich sehe, das ist ein Overwatch-Clip, mehr sehe ich in der Vorschau nicht.
Oh, ein Exclusive-Clip, da muss ich leiser machen.
Der geht schon ab teilweise. Bam, in your face. Zack, weggehämmert.
Alter! Was geht mit ihm denn ab?
Das Game gelieft dabei, oder was?
Also, wie er die Transition hier unten macht, also hier unten, dass der Text überplantet, verstehe ich ehrlich gesagt nicht so ganz. Wie macht er das denn?
Das ist keine J-Hurri-Animation am Start.
Es ist hier auch nichts drin. Also, wie er die Überplant-Animation macht, verstehe ich nicht.
Wobei, der navigiert auch nicht von Seite zu Seite, das ist alles innerhalb von einer Anwendung, ne?
Jaja, das hat er alles in Single-Page. Der hat das quasi alles in einer Seite. Der navigiert gar nicht von einer Seite zu anderen.
Das ist alles innerhalb von einer Seite.
Naja, ich glaube, damit können wir leben, dass es so umswitcht.
Ich würde ja daraus auch eine komplette Single-Page-Applikation machen, dann bräuchte ich aber irgendeinen Vue.js-Buildstab und Vue.js-Komponenten, das hab ich keinen Bock drauf.
Webpack ist die Ausgeburt des Bösen, ey.
So Leute, ich geh jetzt aufs Klo und was essen.
Ich glaube, wir haben unser Ziel für heute erreicht.
Ich werde das morgen noch ein bisschen hübsch machen, dann werde ich den beiden schicken.
Dann können sie es ja mal ausprobieren.
Irgendwie weit das tut, was wir noch einbauen können.
Das ist immer ganz gut, wenn man was gebastelt hat und das quasi die Leute relativ früh mal testen lässt.
Nicht, dass man quasi komplett dran vorbei baut.
Und wenn das morgen getestet ist, dann machen wir vielleicht morgen Mittag oder morgen Abend noch ein paar Sachen rein, die aufgefallen sind.
Dann sind wir dabei.
Aber ich finde das Interface echt ganz nice geworden.
Das ist gut, habe ich jetzt schon zehnmal gesagt oder so, aber gefällt mir trotzdem.
Key, Statistiken, sonst was.
Paging müssen wir hier noch einbauen, was wir auch noch unbedingt einbauen müssen, was da jetzt gar nicht drin ist.
Was wahrscheinlich gleich mal morgen Probleme machen wird, ist, dass wenn man Rechner, zwei Rechner zeitgleich aufbaut, dass dann beide Rechner sich den gleichen Key crappen.
Wir müssen doch unbedingt so ein Pendingfeld einführen, das quasi solange der zweite Key nur angefragt ist, aber noch nicht aktiviert, dass der Key dann nicht an einen zweiten Rechner rausgegeben wird.
Erst wieder, wenn die Aktivierung bei dem anderen fehlgeschlagen ist.
Aber zum Testen mit ein, zwei Keys morgen sollte das auch so hinhauen.
So Leute, dann sehen wir uns morgen wahrscheinlich wieder.
Macht's gut, bis dann, CO.